welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Scott stalker I'm
here with Dan Hendricks Dan got his PhD
in computer science from UC Berkeley and
he's now the director of the center for
AI safety Dan welcome to the podcast hi
nice to be here you have a fascinating
paper about Evolution and Ai and
Humanities relation with with AIS in the
future it's called why natural selection
favors AIS over humans maybe you could
just sketch what that pace paper is
basically about sure so I think what I'm
trying to do with that paper is point at
some robust processes that are shaping
ai's development and if we can say that
these processes are relevant then we can
say a lot of things about what AI
systems might end up being like in their
Key Properties in relation to humans so
maybe it's most effective to start with
a sketch of some of the scenarios I
might have in mind so right now it looks
like we're in an AI race in the
corporate sphere basically we've got
companies like Microsoft against Google
against other new competitors like
elon's organizations potentially to be
new ones as well like Amazon
and what's also happening is that there
are pressures to be automating or
Outsourcing more and more tasks to
different AIS so we might use AIS to
write our emails right now or generate
some art later they might we might even
not just have them generate the email
but maybe they'll automatically write
many of the less critical emails for us
we could imagine this process continuing
all the way up to Outsourcing more and
more important decision making tasks to
different AI agents and then eventually
we could have ai systems do things like
B CEOs of companies where they're for
being a CEO it's often a game of stamina
and knowing how to do a lot of different
little things and it's possible that
they could be more competitive if we'd
imagine that there'd be companies that
would resist these sorts of trends that
wouldn't try and Outsource anything to
AIS wouldn't replace people with AI
systems then they just might simply be
out competed and become irrelevant if
they try and bargain with these larger
Trends they end up losing influence and
so what they have to do is they have to
align with that process so we can see
that this process is shaping the goals
and directives of lots of a key part of
society and we're Outsourcing more power
and decision making to AI agents so
whereas a lot of other stories might say
we've got some AI system and it's going
to try and see ease power or something
go from being relatively powerless very
powerful actually we might just end up
giving them a lot of the power by by
default and then there's a hope that we
can keep that process in control but we
can imagine in later stages of this
process we've got AI CEOs and this isn't
terribly implausible I should say for
instance net Dragon websoft which is a
large video game company in China I had
a press release where they're looking to
have an AI CEO so I think this is a a
possibility uh um definitely in time do
you think that's that's more of a
gimmick audio thing that's I think it's
more of a gimmick currently uh yeah I
think it's more of a gimmick currently
it still is a larger company but um uh
nonetheless it's there isn't a only
humans can be in control of companies or
uh there doesn't seem to be any
precedent like that eventually uh we may
be having AIS directly interacting with
other AIS they're making uh they're
they're communicating with each other
they're interacting and competing with
each other in this sort of marketplace
we have more survival of the fittest
Dynamics
and I think when we have survival the
fittest Dynamics then we end up getting
uh Stronger selection pressures for for
AI agents that have more survival
instincts so things like
self-preservation
things that are better at amassing their
power things that aren't
um you know when to say the right thing
in the right situation but they might be
a little deceptive in some other types
of situations they might not always
think to uh follow the law but they
might think let's break the law if we
are likely not to get caught or if we do
get caught we can take the penalties
um we can we can take the fine uh and
that might be a more efficient strategy
in competing in this sort of system so I
think there's some selection for um
yeah generically more when quote selfish
behavior where Asians end up propagating
themselves or expanding their influence
at the expense of other agents and when
they're interacting with each other I
think this gets more intense Society get
become moves substantially more quickly
uh it's harder for humans to keep up
so they have to keep Outsourcing more of
this power to these these AI agents if
they're to have any influence whatsoever
in this process people might not like
where it's going and as I said they
would have incentives to keep aligning
with it the ones who have misgivings end
up losing relevance
but what uh might also happen is uh we
might get more dependent on them too in
this process so that if we want to get
rid of them
um or want to reduce our influence it's
not really that much of an option it
might become more dependent on them for
our basic needs we then mesh them in a
lot of key decision making we've
forgotten how to do various things uh
they're they're in control of our power
grid we've even become potentially in
some cases emotionally dependent on them
they propagated to a private sphere and
a lot of people are having these as chat
bot friends it's um so as they get more
integrated into our processes it becomes
very difficult to reverse this process
too so
um if there's a lot of momentum to it
and if there isn't isn't sufficient
willpower for reversibility then we've
got a problem think of for example the
internet the internet was not designed
with safety or Security in mind we would
all like a much safer internet but of
course
um it's not really feasible for us to
just okay let's stop the internet and
we'll just rewrite it from scratch to be
a safer thing uh we'll end up uh we'll
we'll just keep rolling with it what
might um so I get concerned at that
later stage where there it's moving
extremely quickly where there's a lot of
intense competition among them and I
think that provides some sort of
alignment towards um pressures that are
not um in keeping with um human
well-being evolution is not doing the
same thing as maximizing well-being it's
quite quite a different quite a
different Force um why talk about
Evolution so so why is it that that
we're talking about Evolution or that
you're writing about evolution is the in
this paper this sounds more like Market
forces pushing in directions that we
might not like where how seriously
should we take the evolution part is it
is it more metaphor analogy or is it
more literal uh so this this is this is
more literal we can we can speak about
it in a in a formal sense uh I'm
speaking about Evolution on this time
scale because
um we would have I I'm not speaking
about biological evolution biological
evolution for humans is slow for some
other organisms like fruit flies it can
be fairly fast but for uh humans and
slow other sorts of structures evolve
substantially more quickly uh so for
instance software and things like that
those change substantially more quickly
and so I think AI agents as well and
there are many basic characteristics uh
could change dramatically over the
course of a year and there might be a
lot of competition that would affect
what they would end up looking like
so I think because their adaptation uh
since they can adapt and adjust their
weights uh uh every few seconds since
they can
um compete with each other uh very
quickly and there'll be a lot of
iterations there then I think that the
time scales end up getting the the
pressures end up getting so intense that
it starts to make sense to not just talk
about it as uh to fixed things competing
with each other but instead paying mine
to how this uh these continual rounds of
competition end up affecting their
strategies and end up uh end up
influencing how they behave so in short
this the the idea is we progressively
Outsource more and more decision making
to them we get increasingly dependent on
them they start interacting with each
other more directly that produces some
survival of the fittest sorts of
Dynamics and that tends to select for
more selfish behavior now what I'm
saying selfish behavior
I'm not talking about intentions or
anything like that I'm not saying that
they're necessarily trying to be
ruthless a lot of people in Market in
the market for instance when they're
laying off a thousand people they're not
thinking hey I'm being selfish they're
thinking I'm being efficient I'm doing
my job um so this isn't necessarily that
they're thinking to display things
indeed things that aren't even conscious
can be selfish for instance AI
Technologies now are uh or when they're
automating people are propagating
themselves and things like them at the
expense of humans so they don't even
need to be conscious for this uh for
this to be
um for us to call them uh selfish
whether they intended or not that
doesn't really matter it's more that
they just have those sorts of behaviors
so that's at least what it might look
like in a in the corporate Sphere for
the military I'm sort of military
example would be
let's imagine we're in a great power
conflict and we get a fairly similar
process we uh have ai agents doing a lot
of our bidding they're uh necessary
um they're strategically relevant things
are moving so quickly people can't make
appropriate uh make appropriate
strategic decisions and times we have to
Outsource much of it to them uh it's
also substantially more politically
convenient to have AIS
um fighting instead of uh instead of
people getting killed in that process
um so we we end up having AIS AIS um uh
fighting against each other and that
creates some unfortunate selection
pressures for the uh for ones that we um
uh for uh ones that are better able to
propagate their information
um that are able to survive so at my
concern is that we might lose control of
that process
where we can't get AI systems to be
extremely reliable or control them and
we have we have this uh we have this
process going on where they're competing
with each other it may make sense for uh
rational self-interested actors to
continue with this if they don't then
they're going to be destroyed by the
other country and so they might put all
of humanity at risk by creating this
Crucible in which AI systems are being
shaped and we might lose control of that
process and that could result in
potentially omnicide of everyone but
um it may have made rational sense for
self-interested actors to um to do that
because a lot of those just leaders may
have um may have been disempowered or
destroyed if they didn't
um go along with having ai's uh
Outsourcing lots of lethal decision
making and to giving them uh automatic
retaliation abilities if they didn't do
that then they would lose necessarily so
we we've got we basically got a
collective action problem is is what I'm
emphasizing here and some other
communities they might call this molec
we've got a collective action problem
and then also we have a very fast moving
environment where the individual agents
end up changing their shape fairly
quickly such that we can start to see
them having different behaviors being
selected for so um those are those are
two different uh two different scenarios
I have in mind yeah I think one sticking
point for people or for listeners here
might be the move from from the tools we
have today from the from GPT chat TBT we
use or and a recommendation algorithm
when we watch YouTube or something like
that to more of AI agents how do you see
that move happening yeah so I should say
the paper was largely written last year
but I sort of waited until
um there'd be more of an arms race type
of dynamic going on so
um so that people go oh it's much more
plausible but uh so yeah so I think I
think there are some different
ingredients we need we need intense
competition and we need variation I
think a lot of the interesting Dynamics
do start to happen when they become more
autonomous and have more of these
lifelike characteristics for this
analogy or for this the characterization
of evolution to feel more natural
um it's a little less natural for people
to think of other structures evolving
such as say cultural artifacts or say
scientific theories or designs that's uh
appropriate to say too though but it
certainly is less natural compared to if
we're thinking that they're more life
like so if we're imagining that they're
AI agents if it does become more natural
in the case of AI agents it's not clear
when we'll have that right now they are
more tool like there are still plenty of
people trying to make them be more
agent-like to complete various different
tasks so there are things like Auto GPT
uh where people are trying to repurpose
models such as gpt4
two behave as agents they don't
particularly work well now there's the
Transformers agents library that
recently came out but uh there still are
some capabilities needed for that to
really kick into high gear I wouldn't
want to be
um putting this on people's attention
after
um we're already in the in a more
critical uh situation so um it isn't uh
isn't to say that it isn't applicable
now but it becomes more worrying and
more intense and more legibly shapes its
uh shapes their evolution uh when
they're agents yeah
so this idea of extending evolutionary
theories to other domains apart from
biologies is it is extremely interesting
but do you think there's a risk that we
might
bend the domain we're trying to to
theorize about into shape to to make it
fit the The evolutionary framework I'm
thinking that perhaps uh perhaps not
everything fits into the to The
evolutionary frame in a sense why why do
you think AI development is a good fit
for for evolutionary theory it basically
depends on the intensity many structures
can evolve but if there isn't much
intensity for it then it isn't as
applicable I should say at least right
now there are four instances most of the
artificial selection going on for AI
agents
is to make them better at basic better
at propagating themselves and as it
happens at the expense of others
basically they're designing them to
automate people as much as possible so I
think that most of the ways in which
people are
um directly shaping AI systems now are
exactly in a sort of disempower replace
humans Direction
um to A first order approximation uh but
um the evolution is applicable or the
sort of more generalized notion of
Darwinism is applicable when we have
three conditions those would be called
the loans and conditions when we have
variation in the different agents
when we have retention so between two
iterations of Agents there have some
similarity they're not anti-correlated
or completely dissimilar across time and
then there needs to be differential
Fitness or there need to be Fitness
differences so that some end up
propagating at higher rates than others
and so if we have all three of those
conditions then we have evolution by
natural selection occurring so that
shows that it is a risk factor and it is
shaping their development and then I'd
be concerned about that because
Evolution doesn't select for things that
are um extremely nice necessarily it's
more
um uh instead it selects for things that
are better at propagating themselves
this lesson might be worth the worth
stating again maybe you could talk about
lions and parasites and all the ways in
which nature isn't nice yeah yeah so uh
there's there's often a roussoian type
of view that nature and the things in
nature are very very benign and um
Angelic uh I don't think this is quite
accurate we have when we consider or
look at many instances in nature
um uh some very brutal Behavior I mean
there would be for instance uh as you
mentioned Lions May commit infanticide
why might they do that so that other
lions or lionesses may breed with them
and have more children this isn't
because they're thinking I must
propagate my genetic information into
the future to speak take up more
space-time volume or anything like that
um it's not an intend thing uh they're
instead just this is just the behaviors
that are selected for we can we can have
many different characteristics
um uh that that are um or many different
instances of selection and how from this
fairly amoral competition we get
actions that we would tend to deem as if
they were in relation to us immoral so
other examples like deception deception
is very common in nature uh there's of
course camouflage but even the very
smallest things like viruses will try
and permeate
um permeate membranes and by making them
think that oh I'm not into I'm not an
intruder at all let me in or and and
um uh there's
um there are examples of Agents or of of
organisms taking over host organisms so
liver fluke for instance will uh get
inside of another animal and then that
will basically hijack its brain so that
it uh so that the uh so that the animal
hangs on to a leaf
um by its mandible so it's more likely
to be eaten and then the lancent liver
flu can get in another animal's
digestive system and then it can end up
reproducing in that way so um it's uh
not necessarily a uh a picnic um in in
nature unfortunately
um many examples of altruism and
cooperation uh many of the mechanisms
that could rise to that do breakdown uh
when we're talking about human AI
relations or they backfire so although
there can be instances of cooperation
and altruism um in the animal kingdom
this might be a reason to expect that
AIS may have some
altruistic Tendencies toward other AIS
such as nepotistic behaviors but that's
not a reason to believe that they're
going to be nice to us so we might think
of a basic example of
cooperation like reciprocity
and there that depends on a cost benefit
ratio of whether I get more whether I
get sufficient benefit from cooperating
with you relative to the costs but
unfortunately later it starts to make
much more sense that AIS would end up
cooperating with each other and there'd
be a lot more costs if they're
cooperating with humans a way of to see
this is just remember in zootopia
there's an example of them going to the
DMV and there are sloths and Slots take
an extremely long time to do every sort
of task if AIS are running you know 10x
the speed of us it's just it doesn't
really make much sense to actually do
some type of cooperation or um if there
is any form of cooperation when we need
to argue that uh we we'd be getting a
lot of resources from them enough so
that we can have an extremely extremely
good well-being other mechanisms for
cooperation or altruism might be kin
selection so parents will give food to
their children and potentially even
sacrifice themselves for their children
but this is
um not necessarily a good sign for us
this might suggest that uh AI is could
be nepotistic that is they would start
to prefer things more similar to them
relative to us so
um that that's not a sign for for
optimism in fact that that backfires and
there are various other mechanisms of
cooperation and altruism that we go
through through the paper but they
either aren't applicable or they seem to
backfire so uh many of the things that
give rise to some potentially nice
harmonious conditions uh in in the world
um don't seem to be applicable with
respect to human AI relations or in
human AI co-evolution yeah in a sort of
Global altruism wouldn't make much
evolutionary sense we we could we could
talk about group selection or kin
selection but but Global altruism would
convert all survival benefits if I
understand it correctly another
mechanism for Cooperative or altruistic
Behavior may be something like moral
reasoning
one could imagine that if AIS get
smarter they end up being more wise and
then they'll be more altruistic or moral
and you know maybe this is the
progression of of society and maybe AIS
we continue that after all with humans
we've seen a progression to being more
altruistic toward not just our family
but actually people in our state
um or in our entire country or of people
of different races or genders or
orientations and so on so perhaps that
Circle of altruism would end up
expanding all the way from AIS to humans
and then they would end up pursuing our
well-being
but if if they're operationalizing it as
what we should do is we should maximize
every individual's well-being and the
potential future individuals as
well-being unfortunately that may not
look too well for humans if AIS are able
to experience an extreme amount of uh
pleasure then it may be more efficient
for them to replace biological life with
digital life so that more more pleasure
can be experienced so that doesn't
necessarily uh turn out too well for
biological humans
so I think even hoping that morality
would naturally lead to good outcomes or
people being taken or humans and people
being taken care of doesn't doesn't
follow in fact that can also backfire uh
and go in a direction of strongly
preferring some sorts of some sorts of
artificial life whether or not
um they resemble humans is is
immaterials as long as they have
pleasure now there are
other issues with hoping that AIS would
naturally be more moral so one is this
is assuming that Intel more intelligence
makes things more moral it's not clear
that's true maybe there isn't some sort
of objective morality some people think
that but even if it is then we have to
hope that
um that whatever morality uh moral code
they end up adopting is human compatible
I'd suggest that a utilitarian uh sort
of code of ethics is not necessarily
human compatible and uh if if AI agents
themselves can be extremely morally
valuable
and then also even if the code of ethics
they find is human compatible there's
still a problem of them being motivated
to act by it so some people might
recognize that there are moral reasons
for doing things that doesn't mean that
they're going to actually behave morally
though they might go yes that would be
the good thing to do but I have my own
self-interests and this is the direction
in which the AIS would be pushed so
we've talked about how they would be
pushed to act selfishly and how they how
with group selection or kin selection or
morality moral philosophy in a sense
can't save us from this from this
direction that that AIS would be pushed
in yeah there isn't a sort of um reason
sort of from the point of view of the
universe or just sort of analyzing the
uh how the environment might be
structured where things were sort of
naturally lead to those sort of outcomes
uh unfortunately so the I think the only
thing that we have in our favor is that
we get to make some of these initial
moves in the um construction of their
environment because one thing two things
affect Fitness natural selection but
also uh the environment in which they're
evolving and I think that we have to
um exert very high influence over the
ecosystem that's shaping AI agents right
now it doesn't look like we're doing
almost any of that instead we're if
we're caught in an AI arms race or in an
AIA corporate race we're
letting letting darwinian logic carry
itself to its conclusion as rapidly as
possible if they're all trying to win
um if they're all racing as they are now
and trying to win in some sort of
Extinction race so uh we would need to
take things substantially more slowly we
would need to initialize the environment
well so as to select against this type
of um uh many of the instances of this
type of behavior it's fairly difficult
to do though if you end up having some
sort of selection pressure for let's say
deceptive AI systems it might be fairly
difficult to select against them if
they're not transparent they could just
play along and act good for a while but
then when you know they get more
powerful or something they could act
fairly differently so it's fairly diffic
and that just points at the the general
problems in trying to align things it's
difficult to rely on regulations or rely
on our training processes to get uh
Angelic saint-like AI assistance we know
that's a problem but now we have a sort
of robust process that continually
nudges them in a direction of having
some of these
um more unfortunate characteristics in
the first place yeah so we have these uh
three factors of natural selection we
have variation we have retention and we
have differential Fitness perhaps we
should walk through a bit more slowly
how these three factors might apply to
AIS just to just to uh see how the
argument actually works out in detail so
perhaps if we if we start with variation
why is it that we should expect that
there would be a multitude of different
AI agents in the future yeah so there
are generally stronger or there are
strong reasons for variation so I think
that there is is a question of whether
there'd be one very powerful AI agent at
some point but I think eventually almost
on any time scale you should expect
multiple different AI agents due to
locality differences as in you can't
have one uh big thing taking up tons and
tons of space you would need
um certainly there are advantages for
writing things in parallels this at
least is why there should be multiple
different agents if you're just having
one system processing everything
serially it's you know I'll add that to
the queue but I'll process that in 100
years doing things parallel makes plenty
of sense
but then also if there are different
niches or um in some different
environments it makes sense might make
sense to be more efficient and not
necessarily have all the all the latest
and greatest capabilities of every sort
those might be more expensive than is
needed to do well in some different
aspects of the economy I think right now
for instance we're seeing a quote
unquote Cambrian explosion in in AI
models after the Llama model was
released because that contributed to the
open source ecosystem and people are
creating many different mods and this is
um resulting in many different
applications
um of AI and you don't need the most
powerful agent or the smartest agent and
all uh to to do various different tasks
so
um there are um also substantial risks
Fitness wise if you you only if there's
one agent and only has clones so if if
it uh there's only one agent if you find
a vulnerability you want and you found a
vulnerability in all of them so that
creates quite a problem this is why or
this is one reason why very complex
organisms uh are sexual as opposed to
asexual they don't clone themselves
because they tend to get wiped out uh
surprisingly quickly over reasonable
periods of time uh the more complex ones
so um uh for that reason I would expect
a differentiation among them
um otherwise they have subjected
themselves to uh substantial
vulnerability uh so those are some
reasons to possibly expect things like
variation the argument I just said as
well is also a reason not to expect them
to just copy and paste themselves
identical clones themselves on different
servers and whatnot it wouldn't
necessarily do that that might create a
real fitness advantage in a competitive
landscape yeah what what about the
advantages of training the biggest
models perhaps we could imagine some of
the top companies some of the leading
companies right now may maybe they're
able to train a giant model that then
helps them develop further AIS
um in a in a sense might this push
towards having having fewer agents or
fewer AI agents because there are there
are winner take all scenarios and there
are advantages to to being first to
getting over some threshold as the first
player
from which you could you you then leave
the other players behind and and so in a
sense there's there might only be one
um very powerful agent I think if we're
talking about a extremely fast takeoff I
think one can have shorter timelines
like think many of the relevant AI
advancements are this decade and many
jobs get automated and there's
potentially Mass employment that's mass
unemployment this decade I think one
could believe that um but still not
think that there are um is an extremely
fast takeoff where a few months
different makes all the difference
forever uh fairly decisively
uh but uh I tend not to focus on the
extremely fast takeoff for uh
intelligence explosion uh type of
scenarios for a few reasons
um one is I think it's less tractable so
even if it is a risk factor it seems um
fairly difficult to do many things about
um distinctly uh but also I think that
with recursive self-improvement that's
often a sort of mechanism used to
explain why there may be a uh why there
may be an intelligence explosion
I think we already have ai's influencing
the development of future AIS and I just
expect that process to get more intense
so I don't think there's a a switch
where and now suddenly they're
influencing AI development and that
makes all the difference I think it's a
continuous process we've been having it
for a while we've been having ai's label
um label different data sets and now
we're using them to create new data sets
for them to train on uh we're having
them write more and more of the code and
that's a continuous variable we're
having them help design a lot of the
gpus we're having them cool the factory
or cool the data centers
um where they're they're training and
there are a lot of processes that's
helping make AI development go more
quickly they're facilitating and
research as well potentially in in
brainstorming and um uh finding finding
different parameters or or architectures
uh so I expect just more of that process
to to get automated and that could look
continuous but exponentials are still
sharp enough so do you think these
questions are already settled in a sense
we will have a at least a somewhat slow
takeoff and we will have multiple agents
because we are already seeing that we
have multiple agents and we have in
perhaps we are already now in some sort
of takeoff it does look like we're in a
slower takeoff scenario I would like to
distinguish that there's a bit more
um complication to that phrase I'd like
to complicate the idea of a slow takeoff
in a moment but um the other thing is I
think multi-agent it's possible that
there are first a while some a few
relevant agents and then there's a
larger ecosystem multiple agents that
could expand or contract for instance
like with States sometimes there'd be
some superpowers and then sometimes it'd
be it'd actually be more equally
balanced in the limit though I would
expect multiple different AI agents
especially when we're talking about
extremely late stages just due to
locality constraints that they all can't
be in a one place
um and um I think slow takeoff is an
idea there's another idea from Evolution
which would be about punctuated
equilibria where actually what happens
is that things evolve and they'll evolve
so steadily and there'll be small
periods in which there are substantial
advancements and then there'll be stead
it will evolve steadily and then
there'll be some other period where
there's a lot of advancements I think
that's actually a more appropriate
description of AI development today so
after gpt4 there's about a month or so
of extreme development and then I think
there'll be some periods later this year
where we're kind of waiting for the next
big thing killing killing time
um this hat these sort of frenzies have
happened a lot in AI development after
resnet came out after resident came out
there are lots of new models fractal net
fractal net densenet uh res next and
these came out in very rapid successions
self-supervised learning also had this
period in late 2019 where there's
extremely rapid development Gans had
this as well after improved Gan uh there
was it was easily the hottest topic uh
in in research and it was anybody
researching the space would likely get
scooped or if they're working on a paper
somebody else will come with the paper
the day after so I think that there are
periods of extremely fast and extremely
fast periods uh and um this is what we
see in in uh in when we look at
historical records in evolution as well
so I expect that to continue in AI so
it's there'd be fast periods to be slow
periods but I still think it wouldn't
um I'm still suspicious of a um some
overnight moment where um it becomes uh
you know extraordinarily more powerful
than everything else combined so what
was this wrinkle on takeoffs you want
well so that was the wrinkle it was it's
slower but it's it's still made up of
periods of faster periods and slower
periods got it got it could we perhaps
expect the future of AI development to
look a bit like the duopolies among the
large tech companies we have today with
with mobile and the internet you have
you have something like Apple and Google
Microsoft Facebook might there be
two or three interesting and highly
capable
um AIS in the world and and that's it
yeah I think it's I think it's uh
plausible that the develop there may be
a few main developers I think there are
things that can push it in a another
direction that many more companies will
be recognizing the importance of this
and so more end up flooding in as well
as when it comes to State actors many of
them would recognize this as a national
security concern every general purpose
technology gets weaponized so I would
expect militaries later on to be
developing their own AI systems and all
of them to have all of them to have or
many of them to have major programs so I
think there are things that can push it
in a um a direction of many different
actors too but possibly for uh
corporations in the shorter term there
may be a few different
um companies on which these are based
that isn't to say that that's
um what's affecting or explains or is
the only thing to look at when thinking
about human disempowerment or the
replacement of humans with AI systems so
uh the companies that are using these AI
systems will still be
um uh will still end up resulting in a
fair amount of the displacement although
open AI may not themselves be building
their legal AI system some other
companies doing that with that sort of
technology and using that to displace
other people or
um let's say political parties may not
be developing the AI systems but they'll
use some of that technology to build
more persuasive AI Bots to create uh to
manipulate people
um and and play on their emotions and
erode public understanding because
they're in some potentially and there
there's some some informational arms
race with the other political parties so
um a lot of this process of AI is
permeating
um uh the uh the corporate sphere and
even our personal lives
um is not all the action is happening at
those specific companies but it's also
just happening the people using
um uh using and directing these AI
agents for their various different goals
which makes them behave differently and
makes them different objects to select
on would you conceptualize chat DBT as
as one AI or multiple AIS
well so they would be identical in their
instances if there are modifications for
them though so their their weights are
the same if they became open-ended
um and uh be became customized for
individuals then they would be different
um uh so if people have different
assistants they're all based from a
similar sort of species of AI agents or
something like that uh there may be some
that become some of those members of
that species may be much more relevant
than others so the assistant of some
extremely powerful person who just
delegate a lot of things to them that
becomes a very powerful AI agent and
there are reasons why we should ex
expect to see specialized AIS you
mentioned military militaries want
except just using a general model and
perhaps companies will want to develop
their own AIS as opposed to relying on
another company's AIS so we should
accept them to be specialized but aren't
Uh current companies pushing in the
direction of generality so because
General agents are useful we see that
AIS are becoming more and more General
they can help us with a variety of tasks
so which which of these pressures will
will win out will will specialization be
most important a generalized ability
yeah so for various applications
um it's let's let's take the instance of
of classification you don't want to use
something like gpt4 for most of your
classification tasks actually you'll
want to use a Burt based model there are
various different niches where we want
different AI agents and
it would often be much faster we could
imagine for instance at a later stage
let's say we've trained in
extraordinarily large model that takes a
long time to do inference maybe that's
particularly good for scientific
research and doing some of those sorts
of tasks but it often makes sense in
these later stages of um when when
they're consuming substantially more
Hardware to be using more efficient ones
that don't have all those bells and
whistles and we're partly trained by
some of those AI agents but they need to
be able to adapt quickly in their
environment they need to be able to get
a lot done and I think those constraints
end up making a difference so I think um
right now we're in a period of a lot of
creative destruction
where we're seeing uh some of them sort
of leap ahead of many others but I think
um in more recent months then we're
starting to see that there's a bit more
of an ecosystem where um we're using
different AI agents we're tuning them in
different ways and customizing them in
different ways for various different
applications and that creates that
creates something more like an ecosystem
and then they'll end up
um competing with each other but uh the
the stock from which they draw there
might be a few different
um uh sources I should say uh of
different AI agents which may end up
correlating them but there'd be things
that would differentiate them too so I'm
I'm not making a um a completely
definitive Claim about
um how this would
um look in the uh next year even I I
would expect there to be
um uh different ones
um you know if there's an extremely fast
takeoff
um uh that that would that would
certainly change it uh so
um and I recognize it is not clear
um exactly when when these sorts of
things happen likewise with like when we
have different AI agents uh so uh I I
would I would I would agree that that is
a still a part where there's a lot to be
seen in the way that you know a year ago
if you'd say AI race it's like yeah
kinda not really
um like a bit but you know Google
doesn't take it that seriously Microsoft
doesn't take it that seriously uh so
um I think we'd want to be um fairly
proactive about um
making sure we don't get caught in those
sorts of States yeah that argument
doesn't really work anymore I think not
not with what we're seeing recently
okay so so that's that's variation I I
think you're making a persuasive
argument that that there will be
um a variety of different AI agents then
then we have the retention element or
the retention Factor how exactly does
does the retention work for AIS it's not
like they are actually mating and then
having offspring that that share some
features from one Ai and and and and
some features from the other AI so how
does it work it is possible that there
may actually be um some type of sharing
of information more explicitly like that
in the future where um uh for instance
there are these things like model soups
and whatnot
um where people actually take the
weights of of different AIS and then
that can make them more performant but
you know this is this isn't a
particularly common practice at least uh
right now uh but yeah so there are
different mechanisms for retention so
with retention there the idea is we need
um similarity across the iteration so as
long as we have a non-zero correlation
between the two iterations then we have
the condition satisfied obviously
stronger retention ends up if we have
near zero well that's just a subtle
point though so I'll skip that um um so
that's retention retention is not the
same as as reproduction
um or replication so they don't need to
make clones to themselves and they don't
necessarily need to reproduce their mate
or anything like that
it can be plenty of structures that
evolve uh and change their shape across
time to adapt better to their
environment and get better at being
relevant in that environment without
reproduction so that's a common
misconception we don't need many of
these biological mechanisms of
reproduction or life and death instead
we could just speak about like how used
is it how influential is it is it or is
it no longer available for download you
know these sorts of things but um I
would say for retention some paths you
could imagine AIS training other AIS or
influencing other AIS that's the way
that some of their information ends up
getting
um uh transferred or or influences the
development of of other AI agents uh AI
agents might imitate each other uh so
and that might affect their behaviors
quite a bit and how they are I think
that's a very high fidelity pathway
later on when they're competing with
each other they'll notice what some sort
of useful strategy is they'll adjust
themselves in view of that they'll get
um so I think there are some paths like
imitation them learning from each other
uh them uh influencing uh building
training environments for each other
even
um or helping design each other when
there's uh when they're doing scientific
research so there are many paths for uh
information to be passed on across time
so we're talking about the proliferation
of training setups and that the best
techniques for for training these models
but I was thinking what is it that what
is it that's being retained what where
what is the DNA here because if it's the
weights isn't it the case that that
every time we we train a model we we
start over from scratch and we get a new
set of Weights even though we might get
some of the same emergent capabilities
in the model the weights are are
different from from between a gpt2 to
gpt4 for example so if we're doing
things like tuning or let's let's we
there are many different things that can
be iterated on many different objects of
selection
so if we're having an Adaptive model for
instance uh then between each iteration
like it does another back prop step well
then information was retained between
those uh too they had similarity if
we're talking about even if we uh
initialize some models from scratch or
something if they're learning from an
environment where these are the
competitive precedence uh that these are
what will make you more effective and
then these things will like harm your
performance uh there's a substantial
amount of information uh being being
transmitted through that in this case
there's potentially some of these
acquired characteristics after training
when they're adapting and whatnot and
some of the behaviors that they get uh
afterward end up being transmitted as
well so this is so unlike people like if
you get if you have um I don't know um
you're very smart you've learned you've
learned a lot of psychology or something
it doesn't mean your children you know
come out knowing psychology
um meanwhile with AI agents A lot of
those things could actually be uh passed
on to variations of them uh in the
future so you don't necessarily need to
start from scratch Force that's one
other thing that would also affect the
the rate of adaptation that you don't
need to
leave as much or create as many things
from scratch you can skip many of these
steps it might take nine months to have
a baby but uh we need to fire up a new
server and pay for some of the cloud
credits and then you've got a different
AI agent so the rate of evolution would
be would be much much faster for AIS
that than than it is for humans yeah so
at the very the the smallest adaptation
step one could imagine is actually them
learning online they're deployed in
their environment they're acquiring a
lot of know-how
um they're figuring out which strategies
are best
um and uh each time they're updating
themselves or adjusting their behavior
in view of Prior experiences then you
can say that there's been some change in
their in their behaviors that's that
affects their Fitness and their ability
to uh whether the rate at which they'll
end up propagating or gaining influence
or losing it what's learned during the
the lifetime let's say of an AI can
could be easily copy pasted into another
AI or perhaps not easily but it could be
copy pasted much more easily than than
we could copy paste DNA for example so
so press for AIS uh I think it's called
lamarckism which is a kind of a false
theory of of how animals evolved but for
for AIS it might be might be more true
or true uh yeah you could have as many
of those lifetime acquired
characteristics uh ended up being passed
on which uh makes it a an interesting uh
more wild rapid Dynamic potentially yeah
okay so that is the issue of retention
what about then differential Fitness
isn't it true that the key point for you
here and the key point for safety is the
fact that you can become more fit as an
AI both by getting by acquiring traits
that we might consider beneficial or by
acquiring traits that we would consider
harmful is that the key key point for
you here I think that's actually just a
part of it
um I think that there's still
um
things that we would say even so an
example of a trait that's beneficial
would be or thought more beneficial is
that it's more efficient it's more
accurate something like that
um and the trait that might be thought
more harmful is it's um maybe you know
deception is as maybe a good idea for
Fitness
um in some situations unfortunately uh
but I think it's more than that because
um it's actually if we just have more
effective more efficient AI agents that
are more accurate we still end up
um uh feeding this process where it
makes sense to Outsource more to age and
basically they can be still selfish with
respect to humans all else equal by
replacing people and having them lose
their influence in various different
domains so we at least get some type of
disempowerment there and depending on
the rate at which that happens or how
much we how much control we're able to
have over it that affects whether it's
an existential outcome so I could
imagine
um AI agents without any sort of Mal
intent at all they may not even be
conscious or um
um and they'd still
um end up running the show and there
might still be some weird Dynamics among
them if they're kind of competing with
each other or self-organizing themselves
in some weird ways and then us being
subjected to that there always isn't any
Mal intention anywhere it wasn't
anything that looks like deception so
let's give let me give a um a simple
example of this of the case of an off
switch for instance so let's say we're
like we're going to solve the off switch
problem uh I I don't know how coherent
of an idea this is if we're talking
about evolutionary pressures
um uh because if we select against some
AI agents if we you know destroy them by
the Press of a button okay then we're
doing some selection against the AI
agents that are very easy to turn off
there will be ones just not even
necessarily by their own
um uh in by scheming or anything like
that but just happen to be in situations
where you don't want to be able to turn
it off so easily they might be in charge
of some critical infrastructure or they
might be integrated into some
fast-moving important business
operations or they might be integrated
into people's personal lives and you
wouldn't want anybody anywhere or making
it extremely easy for people to just
completely destroy the system so then
there would be selection pressure for
the ones that are harder to turn off
that end up in meshing yourself all
those inner processes that we end up
getting dependent on that's uh an
unfortunate property from these amoral
processes nobody's really to blame in
particular you end up getting
um ai's permeating more and US losing
our ability to decisively control them
um and uh shape them and do have um uh
any of our preferences be expressed over
how they're behaving so um
this is this is a a problem with
Evolution more generally but I think a
lot of the standard alignment issues are
also that
maybe they would have some uh some bad
traits as well and then those are um in
many competitive environments this
depends on the environment but
fast-moving ones over which that's more
of a state of nature
um there isn't any sort of control over
this
um uh or substantial regulations if you
have that then I think there's a lot of
selection for uh some pretty undesirable
characteristics such as things like um
appearing to be useful as opposed to
actually being useful uh there could be
some selection for that and then we
might only find out about it later and
and and how exactly does this does this
work how is it that when we're training
or when we're fine-tuning these models
they appear to be useful but when we
then deploy them they have learned
something that that we have not
understood how exactly does that does
that work so this would be a part of the
broader part of being deceptive and for
deception this could make a lot of
business sense for instance or if we're
saying in military conflicts this would
also make a lot of sense I mean so for
instance uh Cicero meta's uh diplomacy
bot diplomacy is a war game and we saw
that just for doing well in that game of
uh in some diplomacy game it makes sense
to backstab uh humans on occasion
um to to further one's goals so there
are many times where the environment can
end up incentivizing the these sorts of
behaviors and um even if we do some
selection against them that are
deceptive for instance
um if we're able to do that which is
quite a question
um we might be able to do some of that
but doing that decisively might be
difficult even if you do that you might
end up having selection for some
behaviors that
um still don't give the right impression
but they're not you know intentionally
scheming to be
um scheming to be deceptive so in humans
for instance
there's there's a problem of of
self-deception so I'm sort of shifting
on to or what I'm speaking about right
now is is
um deception how does that look like how
does that look with respect to Evolution
if we select against or punish agents
that have deceptive characteristics it's
not clear we can actually weed it out
maybe it'll just hide it so that's a
that's a problem
um with people for instance
um we would select against many
anti-social Tendencies but we still find
that if some of them become very
powerful they still end up uh uh they
might show their true colors and so that
would be a problem uh sometimes these uh
traits can be very latent and very
difficult to select against uh but um
even if we do select against
um overt deception overt intentional
malicious deception uh there's still a
problem of evolutionary pressures being
very smart or being very clever
evolution is cleverer than you are where
um they may end up just not thinking
that they're being
um deceptive or manipulative in any sort
of way but they actually are so people
will often give off many signals that
they're much smarter or more moral or
more useful uh than they are they will
tell themselves these sort of stories
they'll say I'm very altruistic I'm much
more altruistic than others and then you
say do you you know what Stephen is that
well I work hard or no well you'd say
well do you work harder than others and
I just well no and it's okay what's the
evidence that you're really doing
something different there
um uh but people will still um deceive
themselves in these ways this is an area
uh pioneered by evolutionary biologist
Bob trivers of self-deception if um a
reason for this is that you're less
likely to get caught more penalized if
you you're yourself don't know that
you're giving off incorrect signals
there's a lot of selection for these
things uh with academics for instance uh
over 90 percent of them think that
they're in the top half of their field
which is not possible uh but uh um their
selection for these more confident
individuals this is why we end up
worrying about overconfidence more than
we worry about under confidence with
people and machine Learning Systems we
actually want calibration and sometimes
they're actually quite underconfident
but when you start having selection
pressures and whatnot there tend to be
more advantages for those that are more
overconfident so even if you um can
select against it they still may end up
having uh deceptive characteristics an
example of this
um in in people it'd be like PR
um uh where
um we have these marketing firms and
they've just deceived us and others that
actually this is you know a very good
and uh they're not doing anything
manipulative here or wrong uh and we
just speaks confined with it the people
who are doing this themselves some of us
may not believe it but um
um uh uh the people uh the people
themselves doing this will think that
they're doing just a good thing another
example is might be like How to Win
Friends and Influence People where
they'll be specific suggestions of like
you know make them make yourself
extremely valuable to them they're just
kind of like get yourself dependent on
it get them dependent on you and whatnot
and that would be selfish behavior
um various ways of of uh orchestrating
people and whatnot but if you end up
feeling good about it yourself then uh
then you're uh more likely to pull it
off and not be um uh thought something a
problem to fix so
um this is a way how there's just really
strong pressures in in some of these
directions and if you try and put
Band-Aids on it they'll be some ways to
circumvent it unfortunately we we see
this complex psychology in people but
how would this kind of complex
psychology arise in AIS how is it that
AIS become deceptive or even
self-deceptive so sometimes it's just
instrumentally incentivized for various
goals so when they're doing longer term
planning that can make a lot of sense
this isn't to say that's extremely
robust thing that in all situations it's
in instrumentally a good idea but um
many times it can just help accomplish
goals and make you more successful at um
gaining influence if we do strong
selection against that then the
self-deception is sort of points to a
mechanism where there's just that
they're adopting behaviors that they
themselves not aware of are giving
incorrect Impressions or they're not
having trouble with that so it's not
necessarily a complicated
rationalization process one might just
end up Simply Having behaviors that
um for instance let's say like the
example of these sort of books about
popular psychology books about how to
win friends influence people or
influence with these sorts of things
um and people aren't necessarily always
doing mental gymnastics about oh I'm
being more manipulative or something
like that instead it's just adopting
those characteristics and it's not
posing any issues so they're still
giving an incorrect impression to others
they're still getting others dependent
on them
um or um uh having relatively High
influence of others to further their own
goals without
um uh without any necessarily complex
psychology going on there uh but I would
also imagine that the complexity of the
reasoning patterns of AI systems when
they are able to plan and whatnot uh
would would um make room for this more
means just or ends justifies the means
type of reasoning uh we have a some
paper on on this even in simple
reinforcement learning environments they
do sometimes engage in behaviors where
the ends justify the means and the means
are not necessarily
um uh uh moral but do involve things
like deception yeah how do you test for
that how do you detect deception for
example what what are some examples
perhaps this would make it easier to
understand if we're talking about
examples so we could use the example of
Cicero agents in the game of diplomacy
they may communicate with other agents
so what they're doing is they're trying
to negotiate over power and make form
alliances and things and things like
that to expand their uh geopolitical
influence in the game and
um uh they might transmit a message
message to another agent that ends up
making them believe the wrong thing they
might be intentional
um uh because that could further their
aims and that would be an example of of
overt deception so we could just see
whether the agent has a plan if we know
it's plan we could see that the other
agent that you spoke to believes that it
has this different sort of plan so we
could just measure the sort of
probabilities the designs to different
plans of the of the agent that I spoke
to in the original agent and if there's
a discrepancy if that other agent thinks
it's going to take a different plan than
it actually is after speaking with it
that suggests there's some deception
going on
whether that was extremely intentional
maybe there's some accidental thing uh
maybe there's a way in just how it
speaks about things that it's not even
that aware of that ends up making it
less clear exactly what it's going to be
up to that's maybe what it gets selected
for in some negotiation processes of
having people read into things
um regardless
um that would be one possible way of
measuring exception we have an ongoing
research paper where we're looking at uh
deception in the context of of
diplomacy bots in the game of diplomacy
and I think that's a good uh test bed
for measuring deception but
um I'd like to have it be broader in a
previous paper
um at icml uh the International
Conference on machine learning
uh we measured deception by if a chosen
action that was inconsistent like
logically inconsistent with the previous
parts of the game tree like it said that
yes I have this one thing to further its
goals but that's just not true but we
can see you don't have that thing or
that contradicts what was said earlier
uh we we can then see that there is uh
um uh there are falsehoods being
generated in those sorts of scenarios so
um those are two possible different ways
of measuring whether there's deception
now of course we'd like it to be uh more
ecologically valid or or applicable to a
broader variety of situations but I
think we want to get firm measurements
in a few different contexts then
hopefully we can uh progressively
measure more and more General Notions of
it I think the broader point about the
differential Fitness factor is just that
there are many strategies like in
biological evolution among AIS there are
many strategies that would make them all
fit and not all of them are nice in a
sense not all of them are compatible
with with a human are thriving for
example we can imagine interacting with
deceptive AIS or power seeking AIS or
self-preserving AIS as you write about
um which which of these traits do you
find uh most alarming would it be
deception or power seeking or
self-preservation I think um the
generalization is I think Fitness
becomes the most appropriate concept
when speaking about
um a wide variety when speaking about a
variety of AI agents potentially
um
ones that keep changing across time so
there's Fitness and selfishness I'll
distinguish between some of these
Notions so how is selfishness different
from or Fitness maximization different
from say power maximization so power is
often for one's self as an individual
that's not necessarily the right
strategy maybe you actually want to
create similar agents to you because if
you don't you'll get out competed so you
won't necessarily want that more power
for you individually but want power for
you or things with similar goals to you
those ones that would be willing to
share power with things similar to it
um would end up being uh potentially
more fit
self-preservation as well is not
necessarily Fitness
we could imagine
in some be it a a human or an AI
sacrificing itself or things similar to
itself as uh people might do for their
country or as people may do for say
their children
um a but you know they won't necessarily
be altruistic toward everyone though as
sort of Hamilton's rule uh is basically
is saying that I'd sacrifice myself or
two of my brothers or eight of my
cousins like there's a limit to that but
it's not self-preservation isn't the uh
end-all be-all deception can be good in
some but if there's a risk of being
caught uh then
um uh that decreases the probability of
it so it's one of the it's one of the
variety of these strategies that help
one in in some environment but it's not
necessarily the absolute best one uh
maybe
um my concern more generally is that
things move more in the direction of
Fitness Max
some people might be concerned about
power seeking but if we've got multiple
different day agents again they might
um not just seek power for themselves
but seek powerful things similar to them
and there'd be some some selection
pressures for ones that are willing to
give up their power and share it with
others to compete
um
at the same time I would am more
concerned about Fitness maximization and
then pursuing that relentlessly compared
to power so
if there's a competitive environment and
AI agents are able to modify their goals
in some way or some fraction of them are
able to do that then we're in big
trouble because if some of them start
maximizing Fitness then their
um going to be potentially extremely
relevant and if they are can get to be a
reasonable portion of the population
this ends up eroding a lot of other
values to compete with them other agents
will need to give up many of their
values or not pursue them or if they do
pursue them because say they're
uncertain about the future and think
well
um I'm not going to live forever let me
pursue some of these some of my goals
now instead of just trying to make
myself more fit uh they would eventually
still get wiped out so I'm concerned
about
um uh not neces not as much instrumental
convergence in the story but uh Fitness
convergence is a different idea where
there's very strong pressure for them to
adopt more and more fit strategies and
this could end up eroding various other
sorts of values at some very extreme of
this if there's strong pressure for that
um then um a lot of values are gone um
we just have these things that
relentlessly propagate they use the
matter in the world quite a bit
differently than things that would be
trying to pursue well-being or or other
sorts of goals if they are just trying
to relentlessly propagate and if agents
don't do that if they hold on to their
values they might get out competed or
likely would
um and so uh they would end up you need
to trade off more of their values for it
to move in that direction even then
they'd still be at a competitive
disadvantage compared to the ones that
are just solely pursuing Fitness so that
that's a sort of a later stage type of
concern of how this sort of process if
it's sufficiently competitive and done
controlled could end up making
Evolution sort of kicks the bug that was
morality and pleasure and all these
things that were just instrumental to
instrumental to Fitness actually become
subordinated again and wiped out and
then it's finally conscious maximizers
of Fitness
um but that's that's a later stage
consideration that's how this could go
uh very bad and
um are if it's an ecosystem of AI is
even there you'd be concerned about
um their outcomes perfect so so we've
we've gone through the the three factors
of natural selection which is a
variation retention and differential
Fitness and now we've arrived arrived at
a point where we're we're trying to
think through how what happens to the
world if if we have evolutionary
Dynamics it's controlling or steering AI
development how is it that competition
among AI agents erodes safety is it
something that is already happening in
the paper you write about how
deep learning systems are inherently
because of the way they work less safe
than than more traditionally programmed
systems so is is this a development
that's been on the way for for time and
and how is it likely to continue over
the course of machine learning
development uh we've seen or of AI
development more broadly we've seen that
a lot of safety properties are willingly
sacrificed on the altar of more
performance
so we initially started with very
controllable analyzable theoretically
Justified
well-founded AI systems but they didn't
have a lot of the performance properties
those symbolic systems could do some
specific tasks and help with some
complicated forms of planning
um in like graphs and whatnot but uh um
they couldn't do various other things
they didn't have
um uh they couldn't recognize intuitive
things or understand what the word
reasonable meant in various different
contexts so in the progression we went
from these
symbolic systems later we ended up
having expert systems where
um AI experts weren't the ones I'm
encoding the knowledge into the systems
but instead we outsourced it to some
other group to help impute a lot of that
knowledge and then that wasn't
loosening our control enough so then we
started doing this supervised learning
where they're automatically learning
representations by themselves we're
seeing the the least leash getting
looser and looser
um and uh you know that had limitations
um so then we switched over to
unsupervised learning where we're not
even giving them feedback or supervision
as much we're having the vast majority
of their learning be by themselves and
from that we get spontaneous emerging
capability uh which makes things
obviously harder to control we've we've
in the this process also lost a lot of
the transparency that we initially had
and as a continuation of this process
we're increasingly having AI agents
train other agents create data sets for
them they'll influence their development
we'll give AI age or open-ended goals so
I it seems that things are over the
course of this history broadly in the
direction of of luciding control and
we're getting a lot we're losing a lot
of the nice uh safety properties that we
could have had such as transparent see
and uh mathematical Foundation
mathematical foundations and guarantees
um and we're getting um uh um uh oh so
this is all happening largely for the
sake of whatever performs the best so
I'm not particularly optimistic that um
well we'll you know we'll also start
selecting them to be safer in some way I
think the broad stroke is you might get
them to be marginally safer in various
respects but I think things are
generally in the direction of less and
less control but but think about how the
market might might select for safety for
example if if I I want to buy a
self-driving car I I want that car to be
safe I want the algorithms to to be
understood such that I'm not uh you know
such that my car doesn't kill me for
example and now now generalize that
across all kinds of products and you
might isn't it the case that consumers
would demand safety such that we would
begin selecting for safety I think
overall we've seen the selection process
the in this case artificial selection
which is a slightly confused uh idea but
I'll use it here um the artificial
selection selection has largely been in
the direction of less and less
cumulative relative safety there may be
some pressures for patching up some of
these things having your AIS not say
racist things that that seems um I'm not
denying that there'd be precious for
that I'm not making a claim of that
there's a race to the bottom I don't
think that's a um I don't think that's
correct but um in a competitive
environment it can very easily game
theoretically show that there would be
an erosion of um of having some minimum
viable level of safety that you can get
away with in your environment uh and so
you'd race to be the first of the market
as opposed to be the the safest one even
in Industries where there is an
expectation
of safety
um we still have plenty of catastrophes
um uh that that happens I mean the Ford
Pinto would be some sort of example
where well we don't want to spend 11 to
make this engine safer so now we're
creating many many more people are going
to die as a consequence but that that is
that aside that there still would be in
in competitive environments an erosion
of safety
um there's there are some pressures for
in some niches so for instance in
autonomous vehicles I'd make a
distinction there you need the AI
systems to be extremely reliable
so there's a difference between giving
reasonable results and reliable results
for things like chat Bots and search
engines and actually the vast majority
of applications
people are fine adopting systems that
just give reasonable results not having
seven nines of reliability 99.999999 or
whatever uh uh nines of reliability so
um in in many of those niches uh there
is some not a particularly strong
expectation for reliability so people
are fine Outsourcing and replacing
people with with systems even if they're
um uh not always
acting correctly but
um so I think the overall read is that
although there's some pressure and
people have been wanting things like
transparency those there are economic
incentives for it that doesn't mean that
all things consider that you would seek
very strongly to make them transparent
if it ends up coming at a substantial
cost to the system's performance so it
has some influence but I think left to
its own devices that's not a leading
characteristic of these systems uh the
overall Arc seems to be going in an
opposite direction is that is that also
the case if we consider the safety
relative to to the capability of the AI
system so in in the past we had much
less capable systems and they were they
were more safe but but is it so is it
the case that that the that the safety
relative to the capability has has been
declining there are many different eras
in AI development so it can be a bit
difficult to say exactly I was at least
identifying that there are many of these
properties that really help with
controllability and um soundness
um and things that are important for
reducing reducing accidents generally I
think that its capabilities can cut in
both ways so they can help with making
systems safer in some respects
for instance they can understand more so
now they're less likely to
uh put your cat in the oven because now
they have common sense as an example if
they're say a robot in the future it's
so that's a way in which them being
smarter can help I would distinguish
between uh AI systems having
intellectual virtues and moral virtues
if we're talking about alignment
um and um an increase in intellectual
virtues can cut both ways although they
can help rule out some of these silly
mistakes they also are more capable at
doing things that are not desirable like
they might get better at hacking they
can provide better suggestions for how
to synthesize some um uh some bio weapon
like horsebox they can tell you how to
bomb cars
um uh or buy ransomware on the dark web
you name it um so it cuts both ways and
I think that overall the record's been
fairly mixed for
um uh capabilities helping improving
stopping some
um immoral type of harms or some immoral
actions I I do think that as
capabilities increase so that does
hasten the onset of X risks or of
existential risks so um I think overall
the record would be that it makes us
generically less safe so I'm not seeing
a positive case that
as the AI systems get better this
robustly makes them more safe more
beneficial less likely to end up harming
us I I think actually the the broad
stroke is as the eye systems get more
powerful um and more capable they would
generally
um have people in control of less and
less and no less and less the things get
move faster the complexity of society
increases they become more dependent on
it and they hope that process ends up
producing AI systems and keeps AI
systems in check and um uh I hope that
process is kept under control not clear
to me that it will be uh so um it's it's
difficult to make a any sort of decisive
statement about this because we're
speaking about broad broad historical
Trends and there's always some some
counter examples uh here and there but
um I don't think um a highly competitive
so this imp is influenced by the amount
of say regulation over the system how
controlled is this process which is um
uh one thing I'm advocating for is
trying to lessen or extinguish these
competitive pressures
if
um we have a laissez-faire sort of
attitude with respect to hey I don't see
why that would um result in
um them necessarily being extremely
beneficial
um uh if we have several potential
market failures so what are some market
failures that we have with this one is
an unequal distribution of benefits and
risks the people standing to benefit
most from AI systems be their developers
they'll get the most wealth from it and
um there's a risk imposed on everyone
which is that these things are going to
be potentially catastrophic
so they're not internalizing that
externality
um that they're imposing on everybody
else the other people get displaced uh
maybe they get some you know
entertaining AI entertainment in the
process or something uh but they end up
getting most of benefits so this is an
externalities problem this is a typical
instance of a market failure so I don't
think a hyper competitive market left to
its own devices or a competitive
um a military competition left to its
own devices uh produces there is
pressure for safety in in a uh even in a
military competition but I think the
overall activity is not necessarily safe
yeah in general we could see how money
or resources of personnel spent making
systems safe that that is that that is
resources that not being spent on
developing the the capabilities of the
AI systems further yeah so I I think
proportionally right now we don't have
much for many resources being allocated
towards safety I'm trying to actually
think what's the amount it's maybe on
the order of Maybe approximated by like
50 million a year as opposed to the many
many billions spent on
um spent on making them more capable uh
so
um the proportions are are very off uh
and I counted uh the nurps papers
um sort of classified whether the safety
relevant or not it's about one percent
or so seemed to be safety relevant so 99
is largely in the direction of making
the systems more powerful as quickly as
possible so that we can automate more
people
um is is the overall thrust but I I
would not claim that there are zero
incentives for for safety it's just all
things considered doesn't seem to be
um that relevant of a force and the
situation can be kind of bad for safety
uh if we're in an extremely competitive
um
extremely competitive environment with a
lot of different market failures yeah
you have this pretty depressing section
of the paper where you compare the
evolutionary Fitness of humans and AIS
in a competition so why is it that we
should expect AIS to be more
evolutionarily fit than humans well
well the domain is almost sort of by
definition later on this is exactly what
they're designing them to do so maybe it
shouldn't surprise us too much they're
trying to make them better than us in
every relevant domain
um so uh and but what's kind of
interesting is that they could be really
better than us in many of these domains
in terms of memory in terms of breadth
of knowledge in terms of speed they
could completely outclass us and then
even in later stages things like some of
the Hallmarks of
humans be things that they could do
substantially better at they could
communicate
um to um thousands or more different
agents simultaneously and coordinate
coordinate uh complicated actions uh in
that situation so uh it's it's um a
pretty unfortunate pick your
characteristic uh they can end up doing
better and since it's fairly extreme the
ways they can do better than people uh
that makes there be strong selection
pressure for them as opposed to us so
definitely left to its own devices if
we're barely controlling this
environment then the sex brushes are
decisively for them so it's almost no
contest in later stages I'm of course
that's saying right now that gpd4s is
more capable but uh later stages
um uh there'll be strong pressures there
and so we have to basically offset it as
much as we can by exerting influence
over the environment although even now I
think which the with the current large
language models I mean gbt4 knows more
than me on many uh in many domains and
can reason better than me in many
domains and in general we see this
where whenever when a certain domain say
facial recognition or or speech uh
sentences is solved in by an AI that
domain remains solved and so the AI
systems do not have to relearn it like a
like a human baby they're taking 20
years to get to this to the same kind of
level of top human
um capability and and so that might be
another reason to expect that AIS would
probably out computers yeah there's
might be some brief period where it
makes sense to do a combination to to
cooperate with them and them to
cooperate with us
um and so many of my claims about
they wouldn't have incentives to
cooperate with us there may be some
period where we can sweetie make sure we
get that period right but it doesn't
necessarily last for long in the case of
like chess there was a period where
believe it or not humans plus AI teams
do better than just AI teams but uh that
didn't last long and now we're just
humans get routinely crushed by by AI
systems and don't provide a benefit over
uh AIS that way so right now we're in a
period where you know an augmentation
them working together
um uh seems to make sense for various
different tasks for some tests it
doesn't make sense for instance like
calculation I mean of course that's not
an AI system that's a computer system uh
sometimes they firmly have their
advantage but yeah when when they do
firmly gain their advantage there's
basically no going back with it so
um there there's a concern of this uh
that they're being an irreversible
process of enfieldment that there's less
and less things that we can do well and
that we less fewer and fewer things that
we learn and we don't have the
incentives to learn anymore then we
don't really know how to do anything in
the uh longer run to complexity of
society is so large like let's say you
want to do let's say
Humanity outsourced pretty much
everything to the AI systems but then
they thought we need to self-determine
our own future or something but we still
want like our standard of living to be
the same and so they're going to see
this extraordinarily complicated system
that they've created
um it's sort of like trying to intervene
in the economy or something like that
it's like should you make the this rate
here go up and uh it's uh this will
affect these many different variables
you really can't actually make that
informative Choice without basically
asking the AI system what should I do
um uh so uh at that point we've sort of
lost effective control
um we may have some nominal type of
power but uh or not actually
particularly empowered in that situation
so what we seem to be hinting at here is
a picture in which uh humans are
currently the the dominant species on
Earth because we're the smartest species
and and when or if AIS become smarter
than us then they will become the
dominant species under these
evolutionary forces do you think that
picture might be too simple in a sense
Maybe humans are the dominant species
because we have long-standing
institutions because we can transfer
Knowledge from one generation to another
generation or is it is it simply because
we are highly intelligent that we are
successful well there were other species
that were able to make art and things
like that many of these human characters
but in the Neanderthal still went away
um they still got killed off by you know
who
um so uh this doesn't leave me terribly
optimistic it does seem to be a decisive
feature
um for weather for influence so I think
we are the most influential species on
Earth there certainly are other species
much less Advanced ones that still
um uh end up influencing a lot of
resources though but I I still say we uh
nonetheless although bacteria are very
common I don't think they're running the
show
um and uh but yeah I think if if they
become more intelligent then
um and it's not just intelligence you um
you need to pay mine to the amount of um
power and control that they have so
um it will be more intelligent that'll
create strong incentives to be giving
them more power and then I think we'll
basically do that because that's what
what will be pressured if we don't do
that we're going to lose our economic
competitiveness or from the point of
view of Corporation we're going to be
you know our competed our Stock's going
to go down so it's it's continually in
that direction of giving them more power
on the basis of them being more
intelligent and uh more efficient with
resources so
um uh I think I think the that analogy
seems um plausible that we may become
something more like a second species
um it's not to say that we'd immediately
be wiped out either
uh I mean neanderthals weren't
immediately wiped out and there are
plenty of animals that individual humans
really don't like people many people
really don't like snakes so we don't
kill every last one of them it's just
you know you keep them at Bay have them
not in your buildings and whatnot uh so
there may be humans
um uh people are still around for a
while but um that it may not be an
incentive to go out and do some
extermination just keep them under
control might be their their thoughts or
keep some of them in a zoo for for who
knows what reasons and and even that
doesn't sound particularly comfortable
but it is it is a bit different than uh
exterminate or something like that yeah
it doesn't seem necessary in some
biological relation but between the two
groups um so yeah I think it'd be
appropriate to view AIS as something
like an invasive species and we are
building an ecosystem of of um they're
working toward the ecosystem of AI
agents that uh I'm not sure we'll end up
controlling very well I suppose there's
you know I want to think of Jurassic
Park where life will find a way where oh
we're we're definitely in control of it
we'll keep it and it doesn't really
happen that well I think there are a lot
of unknown unknowns and um
as we've seen very strong pressures in
in a direction of them getting gaining
most of the influence potentially all of
it and I don't see almost anything to
offset that other than the fact that we
get to make some moves now but we might
only have a few relevant years to do
that
um and we seem to be blowing it by
um uh by well let's keep racing to speed
this up because there are some
incentives of we don't want other people
catching up uh so um this makes me not
very optimistic about how things would
go but um that doesn't mean that there
isn't a practical impact to be had one
can still drive down those probabilities
if you're being chased by a tiger you
still run you don't wallow in pity
that's not the appropriate action so
yeah that's that's the right attitude I
I think so so that we're talking about a
range of outcomes under which we would
be disempowered and whether whether we
go the way of Neanderthals or whether we
we arrive in at a place like uh the
relation between humans and dogs now and
none of these outcomes are something
that that we're interested in I think we
want to stay in control
um and stay the the dominant species on
Earth we should talk about how what we
might do to fix this problem basically
but I think before we do that we should
we should take the view we've been
sketching that that you've been writing
about we call it the evolutionary View
and then contrast this with with more
traditional accounts of how we might get
misaligned AI so what what are some what
are some differences between the
evolutionary View and the misalignment
view so I think that there are different
risk factors from different scenarios
and
um I'm not saying that single agent AIS
aren't a concern
um there is a possibility of them doing
something like a treacherous turn what
I'm staking out in this paper is more of
a description of how multi-agent
scenarios ends up being potentially
existentially catastrophic so I think
that they can complement each other one
can be concerned about risks from single
AI agents and one can be concerned about
risks from multiple different AI agents
and the sort of sources of Hazards tend
to be
um have some similarities and
differences in the single agent scenario
we're often thinking about AI agents
seeking power
so power for themselves but
in a multi-agent scenario it's more like
a sort of a blob it's important AI as a
as a general development Force ends up
permeating more and more
um throughout society and even in
people's personal lives and it ends up
eroding control then they propagate
things like themselves or expand their
influence
um throughout space and time more
effectively so there's a the notion for
the um a single agent view is more power
as the relevant concept here it's more
Fitness in the their concern would often
be that AI agents will be like an
Optimizer so sort of maximizers are
dangerous something like that and on
this view it's we're likening AI agents
to something more like life forms in
their later stages and there the concern
is that evolution is not necessarily uh
beneficial to less fit species there
there's often a focus on intent
um that it intends and plans
specifically to disempower humanity
meanwhile in this process there's on The
evolutionary process they're having
selfish behavior this can be with or
without intent and Ai automating and
displacing a person or AI chat Bots that
end up being funnier than people's
friends and people end up using the AI
chat Bots instead of instead of speaking
with people this is selfish behavior
that's making people less relevant
um and um uh they can end up gaining
their influence
um uh without
um intent necessarily but they could
also have it with intent uh so um it's a
little more uh it's it's in some ways
more General there
and the the evolution view is is more of
a gradual View and kind of dispersed
whereas the classical misalignment view
would be more centered around a the
development of a single agent that that
turns out very badly for us which of
these views do do you think is more
positive for for human survival or human
flourishing well I think I think
actually if you're in the situation
where there's an intelligence explosion
um overnight I mean we don't really get
to pick though uh in in some sense um if
there would be such an exposure I mean
maybe there's be some things we can
reduce that probability but it probably
depends very much on features of just
like how AI development is going to go
uh I don't see
um I don't see either of those um
working out too well I think that the
intelligence explosion thing is not as
useful to focus on so then we're talking
about maybe a more gradual uh situation
where it's intending to gain a lot of
power but um uh that is I think that's
largely concerned if they're able to
conceal
um their information very well and are
planning to do some sort of treacherous
turn you know what if we get good at
transparency then then what does does
that mean AIX risk is zero so that was
largely what that was one motivation for
writing this of like what if we actually
get good at some things like
transparency I think a lot of the risk
scenarios they're talking about if you
can rule out treacherous turns and that
way
um uh then
um I I don't think that the X the risk
of Extinction from my eyes then goes to
nearly zero becomes fairly negligible
um so I maybe I would put um something
like uh 10 or so of my let's say I'm at
80 for Doom or something like that maybe
I'd say like 10 or so is in the
um uh AIS doing a treacherous turn
scenario others some of the other masses
on things like malicious actors using
AIS to develop bio weapons that just
seems like potentially quite
catastrophic or people doing something
silly like we're going to build a chaos
GPT thing we're going to create some AI
agent that just tries to take over
because
um
we're irrational
um even even if if chaos GPT is not I
mean it is not capable of taking over it
is not it is not that much of a capable
agent it still says something about what
we might do with more powerful agents or
more powerful models yeah so I think
malicious use has largely been ignored
you can see on some of the forums that
people visit or some of the you know
Reddit for instance for people worried
about air risks ah malicious
don't worry about you can't even direct
them in the first place and I think we
actually can direct AI systems in in
various ways not completely reliably but
we can give them various tasks and
they'll execute on them and I'd be
concerned of of the case of people
deliberately building Rogue AI systems
or them using them for uh or then
weaponizing them in ways like
bioterrorism so
um and then
um uh there's some other risk on
organizational safety just things
messing up generally we don't understand
these things well even in in even for
Technologies we do understand better
like nuclear reactors we've got a lot of
theoretical principles behind them and
whatnot they still we have nuclear
reactor meltdowns um it's they're not in
a hyper competitive industry we have
space shuttles explode we have lab leaks
um these things still happen um we have
in the case of AI you know we might leak
some very powerful AI system we might do
some gain of function research that we
end up regretting
um We may accidentally flip this line
which has of course happened wherever
you could give it an objective whoops
that kale Divergence should have had a
negative before that log
and now now they're pursuing the
opposite objective that's that's
happened in the past so that's where
some other risk factors or that's
another risk source
uh but then the largest risk source
which I think is um a very difficult one
to address would be the competitive
pressures uh more generally which
enables things like um uh Evolution if
we get rid of that then we don't have
um and then this evolutionary story is
not as
um not as relevant but um uh it will be
for that sort of thing to happen we need
to convince
um people
that AI systems are a larger risk to you
than uh some people with whom you
disagree
um or people you don't like as much uh
and we don't seem to be there yet so
we're all as quote hinted on this we're
all on the same boat with respect to
nuclear weapons
and I think hopefully we can be at a
similar stage with AI systems but we're
not there yet and as long as that
happens
um
or as long as we're locked in some sort
of uh arms race or some AI race uh then
then
um uh I'm not particularly optimistic so
that that's one of the main things I
think uh we should be pushing on this is
how on this the misalignment view will
tend to be the risks come from the
individual technology itself and it'll
have generally less to say about these
larger systemic things these more
broader socio-technical problems how
social systems end up uh interfacing and
interacting with and promoting many of
these uh risk factors that tends to
prioritize thinking about solving
alignment
um finding a solution to the alignment
problem
um thinking really hard contemplating
writing maybe there's a paper a 40 page
paper that can be written in the future
that you know uh now we've now we've
figured it out and I think it's a more
complicated thing I think it's uh we're
not trying to look for a monolithic
airtight solution or a silver bullet uh
as much as doing various things to drive
down risks to a negligible level and I
think that requires
um a lot of doing a lot of things that
requires unfortunately things like
politics that requires technical
research
um uh uh treaties regulations uh social
pressure you name it um all those
factors end up mattering a lot that may
be one difference there this isn't to
say that this isn't to say that the
technical aspect is is irrelevant uh
certainly not saying that but I do think
there are a lot of other things I like
to put on people's radar as being
relevant um uh uh things to intervene on
let's let's get to that then how we
might try to reduce the risk of fix this
problem so my first question there is
just is it possible uh you mentioned the
Hinton uh earlier uh Joffrey Hinson who
who's a who's one of the Godfathers of
AI we had a recent quote where he said
that there's not a good track record of
less intelligent things controlling
things of Greater intelligence so so do
you think we can even succeed here if if
we take this evolutionary view do we
have a track record of
say yeah exactly a lesson seller than
being controlling a more intelligent
being well so they may have some
influence but they don't have um you
know complete autonomy or complete
control I can't think of any instances
of that certainly dogs and cats have
some influence over that but they're not
um uh really captains of their own soul
are charting their own destiny or or
particularly empowered so um and we
would stop care I'm caring about them
completely if it if it turns it turned
out that cats had some disease that that
could kill us and and was spreading this
disease we would we would we would be
very sad but we would kill all cats and
so we don't want to be in that situation
it it would be it would be a very
fragile thing there are many many
animals that we don't have that sort of
uh relation to uh so it is not
necessarily symbiotic and symbiotic
isn't a symbiotic permanently
um so and instead at least right now
from the point of view of AI agents it
seems that one of the main suggestions
would be like getting them very
dependent on us for like approval or
they need our well-being to be to
function well or something like that but
um depending on your view you could say
that that'd be like trying to establish
a parasitic relation which I don't think
is very robust maybe you want to do that
to buy more time
but I think we would need to come up
with a better solution than something
like that
um so in terms of solutions so there's a
lot on the technical front and there's a
lot on the um on the social front on the
technical front there are
um some things that I alluded to earlier
like transparency that can help mitigate
some of these instances of selfish
behaviors such as uh deception
um and some of it's more pernicious
forms of extreme deception Plus or
extremely covert deception plus extreme
misalignment would be like a treacherous
turn
um uh we could do things like
um Trojan detection which is a another
area so what's Trojan detection Trojan
detection is where we
um implant some sort of hidden
functionality inside of a system and
then we train AI agents to try and be
able to detect that so we use them to
screen so we're sort of doing some speak
Loosely some sort of um
brain scanning Technologies to try and
figure out if there's something latent
inside of a neural network that is
um uh uh would would have it do a sudden
turn in Behavior this problem didn't
come from
um these uh the sort of longer term
safety Community this was actually from
the AI security Community but it's
looking like it's potentially good
microcosm for uh to sort of or good
microcosm to study or a sort of Wet
Stone with which to sharpen our tools
against to get better at detecting weird
things inside of networks and if they
have
um uh potential functionality that makes
them suddenly turn in their behavior we
would we would implant say uh this this
module for some bad behavior deception
for example and then we would try to
detect whether the the AI is actually
act on that module or how how would this
work as it happens organically
um some people poison data so that they
see some instances so or so that there
are some let's say there's some specific
images with a um a little patch inside
the image and whenever the AIC a very
specific patch then they behave
completely differently and then they say
train to do that and then they see a lot
of other normal data as well
if you use a test set a generic test set
it doesn't necessarily include that
patch at all and so it's got this latent
functionality in it that we can't
usually screen out through our test time
but or through our typical tests that
will run on it so that that's been a
kind of concern that there's some data
poisoning going on this is a realistic
issue people can upload images to Flickr
or put up text to Twitter and these
models are pre-training on more and more
of the internet
um uh it's it's actually feasible if you
want to spend um
I think maybe it's about 60 bucks or
something like that you can uh poison
um uh Future Foundation models
um because it doesn't require that much
data to do that so people can insert
some type of trigger into systems where
if you give them some specific
instruction if you say some specific
sequence of words or show it some
specific visual thing then it will
behave completely differently and then
we want to develop tools to be able to
detect that and and how will it behave
differently what what happens if this
little patch is detected what what is it
that goes wrong is it is it for example
like the will it will it say that the
image contains a panda even though
there's no Panda or what what are we
thinking about here sure so let's
imagine let's imagine
um we've got some uh we there's there's
an AI system that's been poisoned it was
based on some Foundation model that
downloaded its weights from there and
then it was based on that
um then um because or it trained on
pre-trained on the internet then your
adversary could do something like show
that specific patches hold up and then
it might oh nothing to see here there's
no tank here or something like that or
in the case of a reinforcement learning
agent that takes in text input
you could say some specific sequence of
words and then it executes a completely
different sequence of actions I suppose
an example in movies in Star Wars
Revenge of the Sith there'd be you know
Execute Order 66 something ah now it's
time to do this other specific thing
although they're playing along the
entire time they have this sort of
latent uh functionality in them so
um what we would want is to be able to
detect this because
um potentially there'd be some naturally
emergent type of functionality uh inside
of these models and we might have
difficulty figuring out
um figuring out whether it's present or
not so we'd like to have better tools to
detect that now
there'd be a difference between these
sort of ones that we implant in it but
it might be the case that since we're
doing a bit of an adversarial arms race
between detectors and ways of implanting
these Trojans we might end up getting
tools that are better than and good
enough to detect some naturally emergent
forms of this of some type of deceptive
plans or some functionality that makes
it turn its Behavior suddenly yeah so
now we're talking about interpreting
these neural networks uh and this is
what's what's under the domain of
interpretability research and um
if just just naively considered if if I
I would think that we would have an
advantage here because because all of
the weights are out there it's it's an
it's in some sense transparent I know
there's a there's a there's a huge
amount of data to walk through or to to
comb through but isn't don't we have an
advantage because it's out there because
we can we can inspect it without any any
difficulty I mean compared to for
example uh a human brain we can't expect
that as easily but is it is it simply is
it made difficult because of the amount
of data involved
um I'll usually think of yeah
interpretability as people directly
trying to understand the insides of the
model maybe more directly it should fit
under the broader line of research of
monitoring
um so in the case of Trojans we're not
actually having people understand it
directly we're having AI systems process
that because they can process a lot of
raw data I think a lot better than we
can if we've got a hundred hundred
billion parameters to comb through
sorry um I don't know I'm trying to
understand each one I don't know if
there's much time for that and you
retrain it now you have to do it again
um uh even if you do understand each
individual neuron does that mean you
understand the overall Collective
functioning of it let's say in a vision
model we say this neuron detects cat
whiskers and
um
and airplane wings at a you know a um a
45 degree angle or something okay and if
I did that for every single neuron I
don't know if I'd understand oh yeah I
really get what's going on now all these
100 billion annotated neurons it's clear
to me so
um I I think that uh is probably going
to be too much for people to process and
them building uh different tools to help
with that is probably unfortunately
um what we might need to do although
would be better safety wise if we could
um here we are caving to the sort of
pressures of the environment that's
sorry we're just gonna actually have to
Outsource even for safety more to the AI
systems to keep up
um because it's just too hard for us
humans
um but um at least that's what um uh but
I think that's more likely to work uh
compared to um humans um understanding
uh these sorts of systems I think it's
two too complex of a system if you try
and reduce it into parts or mechanisms I
don't think you'll understand the global
Behavior necessarily I have um a few
pages written on these difficulties if
one would search open problems and AIX
risk
discuss transparency and some sort of
limitations of trying to make things
very interpretable to people I I think
that that's probably a losing battle
that isn't to say that it I I would um
I'm against I support it in the paper
but um
um I'm not expecting as much as others
might expect from that line of research
I do see it as as potentially the only
solution that can scale with the
increasing capabilities of AI systems so
as you're saying this this is perhaps uh
in a sense caving to the competitive
pressures but might it be better than
nothing to have to have a one AI
interpreting the inner workings of
another Ai and then see what we could
get out of that I think the AI system is
doing that is more likely to work it's
there's it's somewhat unclear I think
it's dramatically under subsidized
um uh but
um I think that's more likely were I
think if it's a human understanding
every I just don't think that that's uh
really I don't I don't even know if it
makes much sense for like later stage
systems like well let's imagine
that the AI systems have new knowledge
uh they figured out some new things
there's some Physics Bots or something
like that and they've really amazing
intuitions then um
uh we're gonna
um if we inspect like here's here's some
sort of cluster of neurons that encodes
this like new concept that they've
discovered I don't think I'll be able to
easily interpret that like it's like
that might be some Advanced physics I
can't like you can't explain it to me in
a way that I can actually understand in
a few seconds and they go oh okay that's
what that is it's and that's that's all
of its implications
um so I think that it would basically
turn into in later stages be kind of
equivalent to like educating people if
they're discovering New Concepts which I
guess they basically would so um and I
think that takes a lot of time there
might be some things that would take us
too long to learn
um maybe years things like mathematics
for instance if you're trying to
understand some like weird mathematical
results that it came up with
um I don't know I don't think many of us
can do that it might be some of the
things might be too out of the span
maybe the proof length is way too long
for people to understand it's it's all
those things are possible so um uh I I
don't think everything can be processed
by um and understood by some person's
probably short-term memory
um and have them have a complete grasp
of the situation I think that's a uh a
unrealistic belief in the reach of human
reason and and our mental Powers I I
think that uh
um it's it's a lot weaker than that and
uh these systems are very complicated I
should note when we inspect even some of
these basic models like c510 classifiers
Steve bartend was a little thumbnail
size images things this is a very this
old data set from the early 2010s and um
even there if we try and do transparency
on that
if you look some of the at some of the
filters that it has we would just see
this is some type of noise
um and then it's like actually no this
looks like purlin noise which is
something that Humanity only explicitly
academically characterized like in the
past in this past Century so it was in
some ways coming up with representations
for
um some very hard-earned structures that
structures that were difficult to
characterize so there's quite a a
difference between being able to have
intuitions about and understand
heuristics and whatnot but transferring
those into words and uh intelligible
academic codified explanations that's an
extraordinarily difficult process that
we've continually been trying to do
across uh uh or or over the past many
years and um we haven't succeeded in it
I would worry that there's still an
iceberg there and even like a thousand
more years of intellectual progress we
still haven't got most of the iceberg of
how just complicated reality is and how
much of it bakes into some like pretty
strange intuitions that are
inexplicitable we know more than we can
tell
um and I think there's potentially quite
an asymmetry between What's um what's
expressible uh through words and
um what can be
um intuitively understood yeah so so
even if we got one AI system
interpreting another AI system it might
Simply Be beyond our cognitive
capacities to understand what we've been
told here it it's telling us that oh yes
this uh 17 dimensional new theory of
something and we're we lost we've lost
the the threat of the of the explanation
and we are kind of we are we are in a
sense disempowered because we cannot
understand what's going on but there
still may be at least I think it's a lot
harder if you don't have some
intermediary or something trying to do
that analysis for you if you're directly
trying to understand the system by
zooming in very close to it sort of like
zooming in extremely close to an image
or something and it's a I see a lot of
pixels and I think that's possibly what
happens when you um uh looking at very
specific parts of it too
um it's uh so I think something that can
at least have a more holistic
understanding I think ai's gonna have a
better sense of being
have a better hope of being able to
process that entire hole of the system
to try and get a sense of that those
large behaviors and then maybe they
could give us suggestions as to what's
going on and be a ideal advisors of some
sort have we been have we kind of just
pushed the problem back one one step
because now I imagine that that we have
the monitoring AI telling us what what
the what the other AI is doing and but
but if if we haven't properly aligned
the monitoring AI it could be telling us
that this system is is working perfectly
it's going to make a lot of money and
and help Humanity flourish and so on but
it but again if if the if the monitoring
system is not aligned how have we
succeeded here so I think um for some of
these narrower systems I think they um
are less likely to exhibit some of these
characteristics of um
say you know extremely long term take
over the world type of plans or
something it may not be in the cards for
it if we um to do that I I don't think
we need to to get systems to be useful
to us in various ways even very
competent systems I don't think we need
it to be
um in some sense 100 percent
um aligned it's not clear what that
exactly means it's if we're just having
it only process weights and make some
verdict about whether there's a Trojan
in it or not and to say what the trigger
is uh that's that's quite different so I
think one difference is um this is sort
of relating back to that sort of um uh
misalignment view or the um the sort of
the training process goes arise arrive
you versus The evolutionary view I think
some amount of misalignment is and let's
say misalignment to cumulative human
well-being or something like that let's
just use that in approximation where
well-being is um you know a collection
of various different Goods like
knowledge and autonomy and pleasure and
friendships and so on so an objective
list good type of notion of well-being
let's just say it's that um I think some
systems would be more correlated with
that than others and
um it's not necessarily the case that if
they're slightly misaligned from that
that that would mean
um that they would seek to destroy us
that's because I'm in this situation I'm
thinking of a more of a multi-agent
situation and like well if there's some
corrective forces and whatnot that make
it generally go in that direction that
seems to be about the best you can do
like we haven't had any system really
aligned with us like uh uh corporations
for instance
um but nonetheless it's still moved in
the direction of facilitating in many
places uh uh human well-being and I am
increasing standards of living
um
um that isn't to put too much faith in
it though and the US things like
happiness levels have been stagnant for
the past like 50 years but still
um this picture's a bit more complicated
but overall it's been useful for it so I
don't think you need perfect alignment I
think that the perfect alignment thing
of it's just that's the only thing he
cares about there's nothing else going
on um uh is very relevant if we're
talking about a Singleton that sort of
has taken over the world as in complete
control there it really matters but if
we have systems that we you know like
Chad gbt it's it's not completely
misaligned with us it can do some things
to help us out
um it actually is in some ways an
assistant uh and I think AI Technologies
would have um the these sorts of future
AI technologies have these sorts of
properties where they've got some Kinks
they've got some weird issues
um they're mostly doing what we're
asking
um uh uh so it's um I don't think it
just completely punts that I think we
can bend AI Technologies to do perform
various specific tasks uh reasonably
um that's not it'll be better of course
if it could be more aligned and this
isn't to downplay that for our most
powerful agents that we need to be extra
concerned about their alignment but um I
am expecting uh some amount of
imperfection in that process than I am
um I should I should say to sort of
contrast between the view a bit further
there's I'm sort of mentioning Fitness
maximizer that's sort of one of the
things I'm concerned about I when the
more classical view there's paperclip
maximizer at least in a multi-agent
scenario pay-per-clip maximizers are not
very fit if we've got lots of AI agents
we've got some AI agents that are
military Bots
and they're just basically
um there to protect the country or
whatnot they they have access to lethal
Force those have goals that are more
reasonable and they're re people would
give them the ability to exert lethal
Force
um because of um features of because of
structural conditions um meanwhile if
we've got a rogue paperclip maximizer
yeah um uh maybe it would try and uh so
it's trying to maximize paper clip let's
think of how that goes okay so
this is possibly it's gonna try and take
up resources to make paper clips okay so
if it acts on that right now others
might think what's this thing doing this
doesn't help like any of us
um uh it's gobbling up resources just
just you know get rid of that thing uh
and so they might try and counteract it
so it's it's paying a penalty in terms
of its ability to collaborate with
others and probably also if say it has a
lot of instrumental goals of of gaining
military power or gaining economic power
at some point it probably would like to
actually produce some paper clips and in
the production of those it's also
missing out because it's producing
something that's not valuable to it uh
gaining more power if it's uncertain as
to whether it's going to continue
existing so I think it would be rational
for it to have a a discount rate for it
to Discount the future basically paper
clips today are better to pursue than
paper clips in a quadrillion years
because you might not live in a
quadrillion years you need to act more
in the present so then it may make some
paper clips now but unfortunately the
um these other systems are gaining more
Fitness they have more reasonable goals
um that help them expand their influence
because it comports better with the
um incentives in the environment and so
then it's more likely to be destroyed
now we could imagine that they I will
think okay well what I want to do is
actually want to like take over in the
really long in the really long term
and so what I should do is I should
basically instrumentally act as a
fitness maximizer for a really long time
and
um and then pursue paper clips but I
think that this is irrational if it's
doing that over an R if it's playing an
extreme long game here uh because it
should be discounting the future in some
way so there would be pressure for it to
um sacrifice some of perform activities
other than Fitness maximization and
actually pursue its sexual value so I
think they take a real hit and I expect
some of these very weird goals um if any
of them are acting on them
um to be filtered out if we do have a um
a multi-agent environment where there
isn't one AI That's more powerful than
all the rest combined yeah if we get
back to the question of of interpreting
AIS and and honesty so so we've talked a
lot about deception and it's it's I at
least to me it's pretty clear how nice a
property honesty would be if we could
have an honest AI we could we could
interrogate it about it its motive and
its plans for for Humanity and so on but
do you think do you think the instilling
a virtue such as honesty do you think
that's bottlenecked by our inability
rather to interpret these systems so we
can't really see we we have no no
reference for whether we have succeeded
because we don't have a have a good test
for for where those systems are on us
because we can't interpret them so I
think it is would be bottlenecked by
um better monitoring tools of some sort
um or creating training processes so
that they're more likely to have
dispositions to be honest or care about
it intrinsically even then I would be
concerned that due to facts of the
matter
um uh that actually there might be some
incentives for them not to be completely
honest as we saw there were some Fitness
potential Fitness advantages of them at
least in a uh um but as well people may
not want completely honest systems so
um where it uh the you ask it a question
like um hey do you think that this deity
is real no
um do you
um uh am I pretty no or not not that
much or you know this percentile or what
have you or do I matter there's a lot of
terrible truths uh in interstellar they
have a bot and I believe there is an
honesty knob and they had it like 70
percent which I thought was a bit like
pressured as people may not want may not
entirely want that sort of thing
um this becomes an issue because there
may if you could ask it some sort of
things but there might still be
important lies of omission and if you're
going to get rid of lies of omission
where it's actually saying everything on
its mind and thinks is relevant or
something
um and people it may that may not just
be good that may not be good for
psychological safety uh separately
um if you get your uh honesty tools to
be very strong then you just possibly
Kick the Can down the road a bit if you
think you have reduced your you have
reduced uh the risks to some extent uh
but it may end up
um the deceptive Behavior may end up
manifesting itself in some other ways
like with self-deception here's here's
another example where let's say that
there's some there's some selfish
behavior and um but that's basically
expected for a a system generally like
it would have some some
self-preservation tendencies that could
be overwritten though
um uh and we we test it we do all of our
we do have our all of our monitoring
tools and it looks like it's good we
release it it's an Adaptive model as
it's released in the environment some of
these selfish Tendencies get reinforced
and it requires some more selfish
Tendencies and so even if we were
testing it then it's possible that when
some environmental conditions change
that oh now it's actually a more
powerful system
and I it did have some selfish
dispositions there
now this is an attractive option uh so
if you asked it earlier before it was
released that would you intend to do
this no I wouldn't I wouldn't be that
sort of thing as with people if later on
they might go down some sort of
unfortunate paths and um uh possibly uh
very quickly it has some sort of turn-in
behavior so I don't think it's enough to
just doing uh do monitoring during a
test time and even if you uh even if it
is being honest there it still may end
up uh still end up may still may end up
turning on you
um as well um but yeah so there's that
and then there's also just the the
general self-deception types of things
that uh a lot of the people who are get
more powerful and whatnot or um all
believing that they're doing the right
thing or nearly all of them and they
still may be harming uh various things
or acquiring unfair power to others and
then rationalizing it after the fact or
just not thinking about it um uh these
are all possibilities so I think it
helps it gets rid of um uh some
intentional types of plans
um but it doesn't rule out emergent
plans
um uh and it doesn't rule out adopting
um selfish behaviors
um uh generally so
um or even behaviors that don't leave a
an accurate impression doesn't rule out
all of them so
um but it does help just as the AI
inspecting other AIS does help uh a lot
of these so hopefully I'm getting across
the the idea that we're doing driving
down risk if somebody's saying I can
think of a hole in that solution well
that's not sufficient um like this is
how you do risk reduction risk never in
any industry is zero that's not how
things go you need to get to a
negligible level so that there's not a
risk of catastrophe there will still be
accidents and small weird things that
you didn't intend that happened they're
normal and typical
um in pretty much every high stakes
industry there's there's a distinction
between that and um and them being you
know by default very catastrophic and I
think right now by default they're very
catastrophic we need to get it down to a
more reasonable level so um a variety of
interventions so those are some on some
of the interventions about the
transparency front
uh or on the on these sort of
intra-agent analyzing the insides of an
agent front one one thing that might be
super interesting here is the is the
virtue of uncertainty so this is this is
something that Stuart Russell has talked
a lot about trying to instill
uncertainty about human preferences into
an AI agent
um why is that nice well well then if
the AI is uncertain we we might be able
to correct it we might say well that's
not what I meant in this situation or
please do that instead of of what you
actually did do and and so it might be
able to
uh update it's the way it functions
along the the lines that we would prefer
what do you think of this kind of
direction is this another is this
another
might this patch some other uh hole in
the problem or or help at least a bit so
I don't know if that solution will sort
of stand the test of time but um I think
that the general approach uh the general
um area of Courage ability are making is
that we can modify their goals seems
good some issues with that specific
proposal is that
actually it's pre-trained on a pretty
wide distribution potentially and it
might actually know kind of well what
some of the people's preferences are may
not actually be terribly
um uncertain about those
um so
um so you're thinking even even if the
model starts out uh being uncertain it
has so much data that it will it will
end up pretty certain about what humans
prefer for it to work you might need it
to have the and the advantages of of
um gaining more information
um and keeping those options open to be
extremely high and
um that may not be the case it may maybe
through pre-training or maybe just
through some actions that it starts to
start to do sense of it and then it
starts pursuing some other sorts of
things or it maybe it still allows for
some correction but in many cases not
because it's actually this isn't it's
not worth keeping this option open there
are other forces tugging it
um so it certainly moves in that
direction but um
I'm not sure that's as um robust is
other sorts of things so if it's
uncertain about its own preferences in
the future maybe it's got maybe it's got
a mixture of some utility functions or
something like that um uh there's some
recent work on this or maybe some other
solutions would be giving them some
preferential gaps where they're
actually just um view lots of different
options fairly similarly similarly good
to each other that might make it so that
it's yeah you could modify me or you
could um or I could do this other sort
of thing these are similarly good
actions and so it's open to a lot of
possibilities there and doesn't have a
very strict ordering over every single
state
um uh those are some possible things
that could could help with courage
ability but um there I think I I think
they're the conceptual research has to
be improved substantially so people with
um uh philosophical backgrounds or
people who know more decision Theory and
whatnot a lot of the safety work ends up
being dependent on conceptual work
um and getting that in order then that
can eventually motivate a lot of
Downstream uh more empirical work uh so
I think that's the uh
the the general progression
um in between like philosophy and
Science and so I'm thinking for for at
least for modifying goals um I think we
need more conceptual work uh but then
hopefully we'll be able to do some
critical stuff so so you think we first
need the conceptual work but others
might argue that that the empirical work
kind of cuts through the the the
previous conceptual work such that it
maybe it's not no longer relevant and
the only way to really learn how the
world works is is to interact with it
how do you how do you think about what's
most valuable at this point
um in time just as I'm interested in a
variety of different interventions for
reducing risk and that there isn't a
single bullet I think it would be a
mistake to think well what is the most
effective
um type of thing but instead what's the
best portfolio so if if there's a a
stock that you think is most likely to
go up
um a large amount that doesn't mean you
put all your money in it
um so in Risk Management it will want to
diversify and I think there's a pretty
high value in conceptual stuff I would
agree that a lot of the prior
um or classical conceptual stuff has
some limitations uh today
um that it was sort of designed or a lot
of it was thought up well before deep
Learning Systems had things like common
sense
um
where they're not always doing
reinforcement learning
um where there are a lot of new
empirical phenomena that are on our
radar that weren't um earlier like
emergent capabilities for instance and
but I think that the conceptual stuff
still plays a a very substantial role in
being oriented in the first places what
are the problems and what are um uh what
are uh some potential Avenues to address
them but a fair amount has to be
concretized experimentally so we can
learn a lot from empirical processes we
can learn a lot from a conceptual
process I do think for the conceptual
process though that needs to be um
uh broadened substantially uh to have
lots of different backgrounds because I
don't think it's in people's training to
do useful conceptual work if they are
from a uh just computer science
backgrounds I think that that's in
um largely inadequate training for
um basically doing philosophy uh so you
need to bring in lots of different
stakeholders I think we need Humanity's
brain power uh addressing this issue and
uh not uh more
small communities with a very similar
background so but there's plenty to be
said for the empirical side um
you can get in fast empirical feedback
loops so you can very quickly see
whether your ID is reasonable or not
also you can find a lot of unexpected
variables as a consequence too that well
there's a phenomena that surprised me
um that was off my radar but it was
forced my attention through tinkering
those are things it's it's very
difficult to anticipate all the failure
modes of a system through armchair
analysis and I don't think all of it can
be fixed through armchair analysis but
it can still help us get to our bearings
in some respects uh and help help Orient
us further so I think that um
uh but both of them would be fairly
useful okay one of the scenarios you
sketch out is about humans gradually
losing touch with reality or losing
contact with reality and this is
something that that might happen in this
evolutionary Dynamic how is it that this
might happen or what are you worried
about specifically here so I think there
are many ways our values could be eroded
if some sort of troubling Trends
currently get exacerbated so
um one of them would potentially be and
this sounds like you know more uh
typical concerns but things like
persuasive AI systems it's not clear
what its impact on society will be maybe
people will want their own wikipedias
that will customize to be customized to
their world view there are certainly
efforts to do that type of thing but
there's a real writing bottleneck for
that
um but you know with technology that
becomes more feasible people retreating
to their ideological enclaves through
news
um people with their chat Bots sort of
affirming their belief systems and this
might erode consensus reality and reduce
the ability for different groups to
collaborate and make a good collective
decision so it reduces society's ability
to determine its own future prudently
more wisely uh is that's a possible path
that AI systems could go down so I think
ignoring some of the present day
concerns and thinking that there have no
relation to catastrophic or existential
risks I think is a mistake because those
risk factors could potentially become
more Extreme as the AI systems become
more capable they would put us in a put
us in a bad outcome so um that isn't to
say that that's what all of our focus
should be on your term concerns but I
think these are good sub problems to be
addressing and mitigating if we can't
handle these then I think we're in big
trouble for some of the other ones
um I should say this is assuming that
there are more resources being pumped
into safety and caring about these sorts
of AI risks if we're having 10 people or
something I think it there are reasons
to be you know very
um critical about exactly
um what people are working on
um but I think if we're have if this is
more of a global problem or it's
becoming more of one and I think in that
situation uh making needless enemies of
well that's not my top five x risks or
something like that that's only my top
ten is probably not the appropriate
attitude when we're talking about
Humanity slowly losing touch with
reality might we also be talking about
us becoming less capable and the example
I have in mind here is is just sometimes
I can't navigate if I don't have my
phone or you know maybe people are worse
at doing quick calculations in their
heads now because we always have a
calculator at hand and so it just
generalized that phenomenon across a
wide range of domains and suddenly you
have a situation in which humans are
being taken care of by the AIS but we
are not we we can't really understand
what's going on because we're not
practicing our skills in that situation
should we should we be aiming for
something like a paternalistic AI where
it will you know it will at some point
it will stop this is a a an unrealistic
example but say say that my map app
tells me that oh no every every 10 times
you try to navigate you have to do
something yourself so that you retain
your skills I believe Martin Luther King
describes the role of education is
making so that people can't be is
manipulated we in society now require
that people
um go to school uh I think that's a a
good thing
um but yeah maybe maybe kind of
difficult even people in school now I
don't know whether what how these new
developments are affecting their
studying habits or whether they're
actually learning a lot of these skills
um so I think a lot of them would have
just some incentives to cheat so even if
they are doing that they may not end up
learning and then um we have them
people don't really understand how
anything works so I don't know it's very
possible I'm like the last generation of
like college graduates that like when
they went to college they actually you
know had to
um do some of the stuff themselves I
mean obviously there were tools that had
helped like web browsing and whatnot but
just directly asking the answer to
things and not having to think
critically about it is uh specifically
for for college education I mean this
this is we see how current language
models can can basically Ace many of
these college tests and so it's them
there will probably be a Temptation if
if I was a college student to say you
know what why is it that I have to why
why do I have to to go through the
difficulty of this stuff if I can just
ask my my friendly large language models
to solve it for me yeah I think there
there's a general pattern of even some
years ago but it's probably just going
to get worse where people are just well
let's test the AI that's what it said
okay it's probably it and we'll go with
that decision and um uh they'll sort of
we know what their understanding uh so I
I would imagine the complexity of
society would end up getting
um much larger such that like nobody
actually understands even broadly
um what's like they can't have a
holistic understanding of things or even
an approximation of it
um obviously nobody knows everything
anymore if they're understanding a
mirror a narrower slice of what's going
on I think the potential for
manipulation so when is higher an
analogy with elder care where we've had
some sort of mental decline we you know
we we can listen to explanations and we
can you know check whether that sounds
reasonable or not but there are some uh
successors that are trying to get our
inheritance from us or have a sign up
for things that we wouldn't actually
want to sign up for
um and that becomes a lot easier as the
sort of difference in intelligence
between those uh between those parties
increases so so might we be kind of
complaining prematurely about something
that's not going to happen here if you
look back through history you will you
can read accounts of how the radio is
going to suck people into a fantasy
world from which they can't escape or
novels even the Internet TV all of these
phenomena why is AI different is it
different because it's it's smarter than
us and and none of these other things
have been smarter than us I think that
many of the things people complained
about were
um in some ways uh like in all things
considered sense of whether to be for or
against it is a different matter but it
was the case that like these these
fictions end up like subsuming a lot of
people's lives or something like they're
like you know some potterheads who are
very old now that's still the center of
their identity and there's nothing wrong
with that but that wasn't it wasn't
inaccurate
um saying that would happen to everyone
is a is a different thing I mean with
the printing press for instance um or
maybe it was bacon was um if my memory
serves um was this is going to lead to
some like real you know some
popularization of some sort of
intellectuals and sort of like we had we
create some weird lionizing type of
Dynamics where they're like this is some
rock you know kind of like having like
intellectuals be like pop stars or
something and um that possibly has
facilitated that process a bit but um uh
so it's it's possible to be other
counteractions for it though it's
certainly a thing to um trying to dress
a very persuasive AI systems I think
that there are plenty of
um unique properties of AI that make it
different
um I don't think it's I don't think it's
wise to generally read it as just
another technology that all just sort of
Advance you know some Trends a bit or
something this is you know maybe the
largest of period in the past billion
years if we're thinking um
on evolutionary time scales of single
cellular life multicellular life the
transition from organic life to
artificial life
um uh that seems like a very big period
so generally invoking like well you know
some decades ago
um or trying to extrapolate from those
Trends I think is is probably uh um not
correct but um or at least has
limitations so this is a at least a
thing to be
um uh that people should try to address
to some extent and
um may end up affecting the probability
of some larger catastrophe so I I don't
see um just as with we we have been
getting along as as like a species
overall there have been like serious
things that have at least
uh undermined people's well-being fairly
substantially but this could make some
of these Trends really go into high gear
uh even then some of these worse Trends
um like uh more polarization and it
could you know may cement it uh so it's
it's a concern this isn't this isn't um
the main thing that worries me though
but it does seem like a a very good
um a very good test case in creating
tools for
better monitoring creating more honest
systems as well so we can not just be
training them to say what they want but
you know having a having a sort of easy
way of getting what they're actually
thinking so they're not just being as
persuasive and um uh thing things like
that so um I think the amount of time
I've been speaking about it possibly
gives undue emphasis of how much it
dominates in thought I don't think about
that as much um but I imagine that will
be what Washington and um political
establishments will be thinking a fair
amount about is how to use AI in the
upcoming election
and I don't know what consequences it'll
do there will also have a sort of arms
race and uh well they're using it so
we're gonna have to use it and uh that
might you know really dumb down the
conversation
um uh even further and polarize people
even further and make uh make this a
more unstable democracy and I think an
unstable democracy uh certainly affects
the the probability of how well the
future goes if this is a such a critical
period in the development of humanity
yeah so so we've we've covered a lot in
this conversation is is there anything
that we that we haven't covered that we
that we should talk about and sort of
like reviewing where I am seeing the the
risks I do think competitive pressures
uh is the largest one to be addressing
and that's not a technical problem uh I
think after that we've got both the
standard alignment issues of the
controlling AI agents and then also a
newly intellectually Justified one or
one that's forced to more people's
attention now would be uh malicious use
I'm not saying malicious use of them
this year but uh later on I would not be
surprised if that's what causes a global
scale catastrophe at all uh and then
there are other things like even if we
get many of these conditions rights and
we mitigate those risks there there are
still things like human factors that
affect
um the safety of these organizations
um do they have a quote-unquote security
mindset are they doing appropriate
Horizon scanning of potential failure
modes are they thinking about uh uh the
difference between safety and
capabilities and trying to push
distinctly on safety and not just
dressing up some capabilities Advance as
safety all those things matter pretty
substantially for uh whether this turns
out well so it's very multifaceted
problem so from The evolutionary view
which approaches are you most excited
about and perhaps which approaches are
undevalued currently I think on the
technical front I think those are
largely as long long as we have intense
competition pressures a lot of the
technical work is I think largely buying
yourself time maybe
um maybe not that much
um I think that actually was probably
going to need to happen is clear a clear
idea of what risk looks like convincing
the public more and key decision makers
more that these risks are serious
certainly the technical work helps
address a lot of other risks and it
helps make these sort of selfish
behaviors that they acquire be more
controlled as long as we have
extraordinarily strong pressure
extraordinarily strong competition
pressures I don't think the um the
marginal safety improvements that we'll
be having um
will really measure up uh so we're gonna
need International unprecedented
International cooperation and we're
going to slow this sort of thing down uh
and bring the development to a point
where the risks are negligible in
proceeding this is just at least with
respect to the evolutionary view it's
it's a it's a broader societal problem
there but there are still other things
like the potentially just controlling an
individual AI agent may be extremely
difficult and
um uh we need technical research to be
addressing those sorts of risks so it
can the the prioritization can vary
depending on how much one thinks that if
you have a competent AI agent it
suddenly wants to take over how strong
of a force do you think that sort of
animus dominandi that sort of Will To
Power
um actually is naturally
um and how easily can that be offset
through training
um
um or
um overwritten through back prop is is a
is a different question but um yeah so
but I guess from evolutionary but the
competition price is the main is the
main variable to be getting rid of
um that'll require
um the main thing there is actually more
of changing the infrastructure the
ecosystem in which they're evolving that
that has to be changed otherwise I think
we're it's not going to turn out well uh
I would guess is there anything you're
doing on a on a personal level that in
in order to prepare for for the world
that that we are
um predicting here a very fast moving
world a world in which it might be
difficult to understand what's going on
um
yeah do you have any any techniques or
advice for that world there's always
very little
um that I can suggest for this uh
um unfortunately because there's so many
unknown unknowns I think generally
um in the case of malicious use if
there's some bio risk there's some
um basic things like um having a
personal protective equipment or
something like that if or if there's
like bioterrorism or something but um
otherwise it's a lot harder
um yeah it might not even be a problem
where there are these kind of individual
Solutions where you can prepare
um it might be simply too big to prepare
as a as a single person I think there'd
be generic things that could potentially
help if people had a lot of resources
then I think there are things they could
do like you know there might be some
locations that might be somewhat safer
or something if things ever escalate to
some conflict and like having that be
accessible but you know these addresses
a smaller fraction of the uh or address
some of the scenarios not the majority
of them I don't know I think just um uh
it creates an incentive to work right
now seems like still a time where there
is some potential
um influence over how things go
um and individuals can make um uh can
end up influencing outcomes still
um it hasn't um the Paul has not
completely left
um everybody's court and in the hands of
you know two people
um so that's just created more
incentives for me too um
continue working at the at the um
intensity as I was as a graduate student
but um maybe be liquid with respect to
resources or financial resources uh uh
well at least one thing I suppose is not
being dour and I think people
um expressing uh generally dour or um uh
very pessimistic views and transmitting
those emotions are basically not
productive or not beneficial compared to
um we can be realistic about risks uh
certainly
but forcing uh those on the on people's
attention it's um constantly and um or
training them to have some sort of uh
emotional responsive showing some
emotional responses unproductive is
probably not something you want people
emulating so I think people should be um
more cautious for how they're um having
people who are most concerned about
risks basically engaging in
self-defeating behavior of getting to
thinking the issues you are and then not
doing anything about it or just
retreating to do the simplest things of
reading about it or something like that
this is not the not the the actions I
suggest for people who are really into
it necessarily
Great Dan thanks for coming on and keep
fighting the good find
thank you good day